بيوتي نوم الجميله
هذا يعني مرض نادر ولكنه عندنا حالات
كثيره وعندنا احنا اول ناس وصفنا عائله في
المملكه هذا يجيهم
النوبه ينامون مثلا من اسبوع يناموا
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح اذا ما نمت زين فانت معرض
للسرطان والزهايمر والسكري والسمنه وامراض
القلب والجلطات طيب
ليش اصلا النوم مهم ايش الاعراض اللي تقول
النومي سيء تقول الدراسات ان اللي ينام
عدد ساعات كفايه ليلا يكون افضل اكاديميا
وافضل عمليا وحاضر
ذهنيا دراسات تقول ان الغفوه مهمه مو بس
مهمه بالضروره اخرى تحذر من اللمبات
البيضاء في المنازل لمبات البيض غير انها
بايخه وهذا مجرد رايي هي تضر جوده نوم
وتؤثر على وقت النوم والساعه البيولوجيه
كما هي برضو في في الشاشات الجوال طيب
كيف النوم يختلف من دوله الى دوله فتلقى
السعوديه في قائمه الدول الاقل نوما في
العالم هل لان المقاهي فاتحه الى اخر
الليل هل العادات الاجتماعيه تحفز هذا
الشيء طيب كيف يختلف النوم بين الاجناس
والاعراق وكيف يختلف بين الجنسين هل يفرق
بين الذكر والانثى طيب بين الاعمار بمفترض
الاطفال ينامون 21 ساعه في الابتدائيه 11
ساعه في دراسه تقول ان الاطفال السعوديين
يسهرون اكثر من اقرانهم في الدول الغربيه
فكيف اثر هذا على صحه طفلك العقليه
والبدنيه حلقه دسمه ومهمه لكل انسان مع
دكتور باحث النوم لاكثر من عشرين سنه ونشر
مئات الابحاث المحكمه في اهم المجلات
العلميه العالميه الدكتور احمد بهمام
المدير المركز الجامعي لطب وابحاث النوم
في مستشفى الملك خالد الجامعي وبما اننا
على
ابواب رمضان فتحدث الدكتور عن اثر تغير
النوم في هذا الشهر واثر على جوده اليوم
والصيام والسمنه وكيف يمكن التعامل معه
وخصوصا مع كثره الاكل في وقت قصير محدد
وبعد رمضان تجي غيبوبه شوال فكيف نتعامل
معها واللي هي تكون اكثر صعوبه من تغيير
وقت النوم في رمضان
وكل عام وانتم بخير
قبل ان نبدا
هذه الحلقه مهمه فاذا تعرف احد غير مهتم
لنومه او يعاني من الشخير او ضيق التنفس
او يمشي وهو نايم فهذه الحلقه ممكن تغير
شيء في حياته اشاركها مع هذا الشخص اما
الان
لنبدا
كنا نبغى كتير
والله انك كشخه الله يحفظك
يعني كذا احس اني يعني
يعني اتكلم في شيء رسمي لان مجالس
عادي حتى حق العائله وكده او مجالس يعني
ما احب اتكلم بالطب ولا لاني كذا احس اني
انا في عياده يعني المريض مثلا اكون مثلا
الاطباء اكون في وضعيه مختلفه
لما اكون كذا ما احب اتكلم في الامور
الطبيه ولا كذا
شخص اخر اذا خلص احس اني انا جاهز الان بس
الجامعه
لاني انا ما ابغى عمليات امانه ما عندنا
عمليات فاحنا في الجامعه طبعا انا كنت في
التخصي سابقا مستكت التخصصي من 26 سنه
يعني كنت بالجامعه
في الجامع كنا لازم نلبس قميص وكذا لكن في
الجامعه هلا يعني على راحتك تلبس كده
انه ما نبغى هو
هو تخليك تشعر بانك في مكان رسمي
لا شعوريا فيصير اللقاء
ان شاء الله لا حول ولا قوه
يعني ما فيها مشكله
انا على كل حال بطبيعي يعني شويه جاد
انا جاد بطبعي يعني حتى مع هذا يعني ماني
عسكري لكني جاد يعني ما احب احب
يارب وانت ما طلبت قهوه بس
شربت قهوتي الصبح انا اشرب قهوه الصباح
انا اشرب شاهي اول اول الصباح بعد الفجر
على طول واخذ لي شاي اخضر
وانا الجامعه اوصل مكتب حوالي الساعه 6:30
الصبح هذا نظامي
بعدين اذا وصلت
ساعه ونص اخد قهوتي ذاك الوقت لانه هو
اخذتها الصبح بدري هي مفعوله حوالي اربع
ساعات خمس ساعات
يعني ممكن يتم فعلها عشان تعطيني نشاط
بقيه اليوم خذ واحد ثاني خلاص بعدين عشان
هذا عشان ندوب منها ان شاء الله لا لا
توقعت انك ما تشرب القهوه
لانها يعني كذا لشيء العلاقه بالنوم وكذا
لا هي القهوه في الصباح ما فيها مشكله
والقهوه مفيده كثير من الابحا تقول القهوه
مفيده للقلب
مفيده يعني مثلا الشرايين مفيده للتركيز
حتى الان ابحاث يعني بس انه في او اولها
يعني مبعد انه حتى قد تكون مفيده للي
عندهم مثلا مقاومه جسم للانسولين لتشمع
الكبد بس ابحاث قويه لكن في دلالات تشير
الى هذا في القهوه كقهوه هي كانت يعني فهو
خالصه جيده ما فيها مشكله ولا الشاهي شاهي
في مضادات الاكسده كثير يعني لكن هي
مشكلتها مع النوم
مشكله الافراط فيها سيئه الافراغ فيها حتى
على القلب وعلى الضغط وعلى كذا قد يكون
عكسي وايضا فيها لانهي القهوه تشتغل على
مستقبل في الدماغ
يشتغل على الناقل العصبي اسمه الادينوسين
الادين راح نسجل الان ولا نسجل طيب
الادينوسين
هذا يجيب النوم اذا اذا الواحد ما نام
يتجمع الادينوسين تجمع يتجمع يتجمع في
الدماغ ويحس واحد انه انه نعسان اذا كان
عنده حرمان من النوم كفايه
من القهوه
لان هي القهوه تعمل بلوك للمستقبلات هذه
تسدها فتبدا تزيد المستقبلات في الدماغ
فالمزيد المستقبلات ماشي بقهوه يكون في
رمضان صايم ومتعود شبك قهوه بكميات كبيره
نتيجه يشعر زياده لانه لما يبدا يزيد حصه
مستقبلات اكثر يشتغل عليها مبسوط يعني
يشتغل اكثر ويبدا الشخصي يشعر بالنعاس
اكثر من الشخص العادي والقهوه حتى اللي
يقولون انه انا يقول انا اشرب قهوه
اذا يوقف القهوه مثلا نقول لهم اربعه لست
ساعات لان الهاف لايف يعني مده مفعول ماده
الكافيين تكون في الوقت هذا يعني
عندهم مشاكل في النوم لكن حتى اللي يقول
انا ما عندي مشكله ينام افضل لما نحلل
جوده النوم جوده النوم افضل عمق النوم
افضل في عدد مرات الاستيقات كل هذه افضل
في المقابل اللي يعني يحب يشرب شاي بالليل
عشان نشطه بس انه ما يبغى الشاهي الشاهي
اخاف من القهوه الشهي الاسود تقريبا في
نصف كميه الكافيين شاه الاخضر حوالي ثلث
كميه الكافيين حتى شرب الماء منشط نعم سوق
بالماء منشط ولا في كافيين فمفترض انك
قبلتنا لا يعني ما تنام ممكن يعني واحد
يقوم يحتاج وحده المياه
وهذا قد يؤثر على نومه لكنه لا النوم صحي
عفوا للماء صحي
يعني اعتقد انه مشهد فريد يمكننا في
الخليج كلها في السعوديه ما اعرف بس انه
الى الساعه وحده الليل
والمقاهي شغاله يمكن ذروتها ما تبدا الا
بعد العشاء اصلا
وكل الناس تشرب قهوه من بعد العشاء يعني
طبعا هذا الى اخر الليل يعتمد اذا كان
الشخص عنده دوام الصباح ويتوقع انه بيروح
ينام بعد هذا طبعا صعب عليه صعب جدا
صعب جدا انه ينام بعد كميه القهوه هذه حتى
لو قال انه انا يعني ما عندي مشكله
كميه القهوه بالليل يعني هم فوضى يعني
ننصح صفه عامه بعد ساعتين ثلاثه الظهر ما
في قهوه
واحد يستطيع ينام بالليل يعني ممكن احنا
نتعرض بعدين النوم الطبيعي اللي الله
خلقنا عليه يعني لكن هذه مشكله لهالسبب في
كثير من دراسات على المحليه ممكن تعرضها
بعدين
الامور العالميه لما يطلع مثلا يقول لك
اقل دول ينامون بالعالم السعوديه دايم تجي
من الخمس الاوائل في هذا دائما
خمس وائل في اقل في اقل وفي اواخر في اخر
الاحصاءات يعني يمكن كانت اليابان
يمكن الاولى والسعوديه تجي الثانيه يعني
اليابان كانوا ينامون حوالي اقل من ست
ساعات 858 يمكن السعوديه ست ساعات وسبق
هذا بالنسبه للبالغين
فهذا احد الاسباب انه النوم قليل طبعا
اليابان وشرق اسيا انا يعني كونه يعني انا
من موصيل جميع الاسئل طب النوم ولتواصل
كثير مع الباحثين والزملاء في في اسيا
اعرف انهم هم عندهم مشكله بس مشكلتهم انه
العمل يعملون كثير وايضا طلابهم يتحصلوا
على اساس التنافس العالي يعطونه يدرس
بالمدرسه دورات مكثفه بعد طول الوقت
والطال بيدرس اساس انه في تنافس عاليه بده
يدخل وكذا عندنا لا بسبب السلوكيات او نمط
الحياه اللي اللي يؤثر على ما يخلي الشخص
ينام احنا في مسح عملناه ومسح حدا عملناه
من قديم يعني حولنا نعمل مسح جديد بس تعثر
البحث لاحظ هذا مس عملناه عام 99 ميلادي
مسح قد نعينا عشوائيه من المدارس
الابتدائيه
وجدنا ذاك الوقت مقارنه
بالدراسات المنشوره في الغرب وفي الشرق
طلابنا اقل طلاب ينامون بالليل اقل طلاب
ينامون بالليل هذا لاحظ مع 99 سنه
تكنولوجيا زادت ممكن التكنولوجيا بعدين
تاثيرها وش اللي حصل الان وجدنا ايضا شيء
غريب انه 40% من عينه الدراسه يخدم قيلوله
بالنهار والقيلوله طويله قد تكون ثلاث
ساعات معروف انه في السن هذا تكلم من ست
الى 12 سنه او خمسه الى 11 سنه في السن
هذا الاطفال ما يحتاج ان يقيلون ابدا ابدا
ليش يقيلون الاطفال لانهم ما ينام بالليل
كفايه
يسهل بالليل
مدارسنا في الصباح مبكره
الان اسمعنا من بعض المدرسين والاهالي
اللي يجون انه الطلاب يروح بعضهم مواصل ما
نام جينا بعدين في الابتدائي اعرف المدارس
يعني هذا ما وثقناها في بحث
حكايات يعني قد تكون هذا لكن ما وثقناه
انه حوالي 14% ذاك الوقت من طلاب المدارس
الابتدائيه ينامون بالفصل
هذا عام 99 وهذا لاحظ انه انت احنا كنا
نسال الاباء والامهات قد يكون الطفل ينام
فهي بالنسبه في اضعف الاحتمالات
تقلل من نسبه الحقيقه تكون اعلى قد يكون
ينام هم ما يدرون انه ينام اصلا
ولا في الاضاءات الان يعني اذا تحب نستان
في موضوع الاضاءات والنوم والسهل نستانسل
فيها قليلا يعني
يعني احنا قد يكون عندنا الاضاءات
الداخليه في المنازل بالليل اعلمنا
بالنهار
الداخلي لانه في الداخلي احيانا في النهار
ما يولعوا لمبات على الشبابيك
والشبابيك المحل لكن بالليل عندنا اغلب
الناس ايضا هذا ما درسناها لكن يعني من
الزيارات للاصدقاء وللقائى وكذا يحبون
اللون الابيض هذا كان
هذا غني بقصير الموجه الضوء قصير الموجه
طبعا الضوء الاخطيف قصير الموجه الضوء
الازرق لحوالي 400 480
هذا هو اكثر شيء يؤثر على الساعه
المستقبلات خاصه بجنقيه العين
ومرتبطه بقاع الدماغ مركز الساعه
البيولوجيه بعدين بنود الصنوبريه
فتعوض هذا الضوء يقلل من قد يصل الى الصفر
احنا نتعرض ضوء عاليه جدا بالليل
ونتعرض لها ايضا من الاجهزه اللوحيه
والكمبيوتر لانه فيها كميه عاليه من الضوء
الازرق
والتاثير هذا وش يؤثر هذه ياثر ياخر مرحله
النوم
يخلينا نتاخر في نومنا بالليل بالذات
الشباب والمراهقين اللي عندهم قابليه
يتاخروا انهم لانه الانسان
يعني الطفل حتى سنه عشر سنوات عنده ساعته
متقدمه يعني يحب ينام بدري طبيعته من عشر
الى 20 بدا يتاخر عشرين يكون اسوا فتره
يعني من 15 هو يحب يسحب اصلا طبيعته
كبير بالسن يبدا بعدين يحب ينام بدري
نمط القديم قد يكون ساعات نوم اقل فاحنا
نخلق لهم هذا الجو وهذا ايضا وجدوه في بعض
الابحاث اللي اجريت على يعني هي دراسات حق
نتايجها مختلفه لكن في اجود الدراسات ما
اعرف يعني هي ما هي الكلمه المناسبه انه
نقول يعني مجتمعات بدائيه المجتمعات اللي
ما دخلت في العالم الصناعي الى الان يعني
نقول مجتمعات ما زال تعتمد مثلا على الصيد
وعلى الزراعه وكذا ما عندهم كهرباء
ويكونوا من نفس الجنس مهم يعني ممكن انا
اعمل مثلا دراسه في تويوتا اقارنها مثلا
بعرض السعودي
لكن لما يكون من نفس الجنس احدى الدراسات
عملت على منطقه في شمال الارجنتين على نفس
الجنس منطقه دخلتها الكهرباء الناس تحولت
منطقه صناعي منطقه اخرى لا وفي ابحاث
كثيره لكن هذه من افضل الدراسات مع نفس
الجنس ونفس المنطقه ونفس العادات وجدوا في
تاخروا في النوم في المنطقه اللي فيها
كهرباء وقله في عدد ساعات النوم
بدون شك انه يعني الله خلقنا نتحدث للضوء
الصباح ونظلام في المساء وهذا يضبطنا
الساعه البيولوجيه وهذا ما خلق عبث
فالنوم وظيفه وظيفه وليس عاده وليس راحه
فقط نوم وظيفه مثله وظائف اي وظيفه اخرى
لو حبيت نسترسل فيها بنسترسج في موضوع
الوظائف النوم كنا ندخل فيها ونستوسل فيها
بس انا الحين قلت الاضاءه
انت حددتها الاضاءه البيضاء
فاذا انا خليته البيت صفرا بيصير افضل
يعني قد يكون افضل لانه يزيد فيه الضوء
الاحمر وايضا تقول لي اضاءه في المساء
خافته في الليل احنا نحب نضاعه القويه في
الليل لا نفوت تكون في الليل اضاءه خافته
ما تكون السحابي يعني لا بس كون اضاءه
خافته ما تكون اضاءه قويه جدا هذه يسمونها
اوفيس لايت هذا اضاءه اضاءه المكاتب هذه
في الاوفيس تكون في العمل لكنه في المنزل
المفروض ما يكون اوفيس لايت
اشياء خفيفه هذه بالضبط وايضا انا اقول
الكثير من الناس عندهم مشاكل في النوم
يفعل تطبيق
وهذا مهم لانه قدره الشخص على استقباله
الضوء تختلف من شخص لاخر مش اهميه استقبال
الضعف النهار لضبط الساعه البيولوجيه
فياثر على النوم
مفيد للفيتامين
في شغله يعني احنا لو فكرنا موضوع معايره
الساعه كل يوم تعال حتى دقيقه يعملها
معايده كل يوم
الساعه البيولوجيه هو الضوء في عده عوامل
مهمه الضعف في الاكل واشياء وقد نتعرض لها
ايضا لانه في ساعه مركزيه
في قاعه الدماغ وفي ساعات طلبيه كل خليه
فيها ساعه بيولوجيه طرفيه
لازم يكون في تناسق بين الساعه المركزيه
والساعات الطرفيه
وتناسق بين السايب وجيه في الجسم ككل
والساعه الخارجيه اللي هي الليل والنهار
الخارج اللي احنا نعيش فيه لو ترك الناس
في غرفه بدون اضاءه او اضاءتها خافته
طول قليلا وش الساعه المعياريه او
المثاليه هو ساعه تقريبا يعني احنا نكون
عاده يعني بقليل لكن اللي عملنا المعايره
اليوميه
تعرض للضوء طبعا في نقطه ماده تهمكم ولا
لا انا عندي ابحاث انا كتبت عندي اهتمام
في موضوع كتبت كثير في موضوع النوم من
موضوع اسلامي يعني كان عنا هذا مقالات
علميه انجليزي علميه محكمه يعني سليب وما
اسلمك مثلا وبعدين قرانك نظرات قرانيه الى
النوم
ومثلا مسلم مسلم سكولار
العلماء المسلمين طبعا انا لما اكتب فيها
ما اكتب من اعجاز لاني انا انا بالنسبه لي
القران والاشياء معجزه ما يحتاج اثبت انا
عشان افهم في الايه وقد يساعدني اني اطلع
بفرضيات بحثيه لان انا باحث طبيب وباحث
اكاديمي فعشان اطلع بنظريات بحثيه قد
تساعدني وطلعنا بنظريات واشياء ساعدتنا
مثلا لما اتامل في سوره الكهف مثلا يعني
ذات الشمال كان الضوء يدخل يدخل بالليل
وبالنهار يدخل على الكهف الضوء طبعا
المفسرين فسقوها لهم مفهوم كطبيب مختص في
طبنا في ابحاث النوم مهم الضوء لضبط
الساعه البيولوجيه للاشخاص لانه وجدوا انه
حتى الضوء
الضوء والشخص نائم اذا كان اضاءه قويه في
الغرفه يؤثر على افراز هرمون الميلاتوني
مهم قد متعوده للوظيفه لاحقا حتى والشخص
نائم اذا في اضاءه قوي قد تؤثر قد ترفع
الضغط قليلا اضاءه القويه الساطعه والواحد
نايم بالغرفه فهذا مثلا من ضبط الساعه
البيولوجيه طبعا
اصحاب الكهف احنا كتبنا يعني فيها كثير
جدا فيها كثير علامات بس منها اللي يهمنا
احنا قضيه الضوء
وتحسبهم ايقاظا وهم وقود يعني انه قد تكون
مفتوحه ايضا استقبل الضوء يكون اعلى وهم
وقود ايضا لانهم معناه انه قد يكون يغمش
لما يرمش مهم لحمايه العلم مفتوحه الشخص
يصير فيها بعدين القونيه يصير في مشاكل
لكن انا اللي يهمني في موضوع النوم الضوء
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
الضوء مهم اساسي لضبط الساعه البيولوجيه
لذلك في السابق الناس ما كان عندهم مشاكل
كثيره في الصعبه مشاكل كثيره في
الصعبولوجيه الان بدايه الشباب يعني شهاده
كثيره صعوبه في الاستيقاظ في الصباح كثير
من المقطع في العياده
السنويه في الجامعه تبدا في السن هذا عنده
في بدايه حياته المهنيه
عندهم هذه المشكله هل هي مشكله ولا
المنطقين الانسان يصحى وهو تعبان لا
المفروض انسان ما تعبان هم عندهم شباب
هذول مشكله انهم بالليل ما يجي النوم
بالليل اذا على الساعتين ثلاثه توه ينام
بعدين
راح يكون تعبان جدا نعسان طول اليوم يتنشط
يكون انشط بالليل يقول لك لو اجهدت نفسي
على اساس انام بالليل ينام بالليل ساعه
ساعتين ويقوم لانه كانها قيلوله للشخص
اللي متعود ينام بالليل
لانه
اللي يحدد انه نام بالليل مثلا انسان
البالغ يحتاج من سبع ساعات نوم قد ايضا
تعرض للمختلف الاعمال لانه هذه فيها
توصيات وطنيه سعوديه لكن سبع سبع ساعات
النوم في عاملين يحددون مثلنا الحاجه الى
النوم ان واحد وهذا لها علاقه بالناقل
ادونيسيه يتكلم عنه في موضوع القهوه
والموضوع الثاني في الساعه البيولوجيه
اللقاء اليومي واللي يشتغل على الكثير
نقص النوم او عدم كفاله النوم خليك تنام
ممكن تاخذ قيلوله يوم ما نمت متعود تنام
بالليل عندك ظرف كل منها
زياده فهو الميلاتونين في انخفاض في درجه
حراره الجسم وتغيرات اخرى في الهرمونات في
الجسم واللي يعمل تعزيز او قنصليه النوم
يستمر في تغيرات تزيولوجيه النوم يستمر
الى سبعه ثمان ساعات وهذه التغيرات اتبعها
امور كثيره يعني الله يكرمك واحد مثلا ما
يحتاج دوله المياه نيسان طبيعي
ثمان ساعات ما يجوع
ما يجوع ويقوم انا بقوم صباع الانسان
طبيعي ما يقوم جيعان يعني فطور خفيف لكن
ثمان ساعات وهو صاحي وحتى ما يشتغل قاعد
يجوع
كل هذه
يعني هذا كله ما هو يعني شيء انك انت طفيت
الفيش لا في عمل في الجسم على كل الخلايا
عمل نشيط جدا قد تعرض له عمل مشيط جدا هذا
وظيفه لازم تنجز خلال النوم اذا ما انجزت
يمقط الاعضاء والخلايا فاستيقاظك
استيقاظك من النوم علشان تروح دوره مياه
او انك تكون جوعان هذا غير طبيعي غير
طبيعي غير طبيعي الانسان الطبيعي يعني
مثلا استيقاظ الشخص لوحده المياه
للتبول يعني المشاهدين والسامعين
وش السبب
طبعا في ناس يكون عنده مثلا مرض السكر
ويكون السكري ما هو مسيطر عليه
طيبه والله
يكون عنده مشاكل في الكلى يعني بالعربي
الفصحى كلها في الكلى يكون في مشاكل ايضا
في مشكله يكون مثلا الاشخاص اللي مثلا
تجاوزوا 45 50 عنده مشكله في الاشخاص
الاشياء اللي يعرفها الجميع قد يكون من
الاشخاص اللي يشربون منبهات قهوه وشاهي
كثير بالليل لانه هذه للبول بالذات القهوه
قوي للبول قهوه للبول
لكن في امور ناس ما تدري عنها وشائع جدا
اكثر قد يكون من البروستاتا اللي هو انقطع
التنفستنا النوم
احد اهم الاسباب تخلي الشخص يستيقظ
طبعا كل ما يكبر الشخص بالسن لكن حتى
السيدات قد يطل ويقوم بالليل لكن الانسان
الطبيعي في العاده لا يحتاجون وما يحتاج
يقوم ياكل بالليل اذا هو اكل وجبات
والعاديه
اضطراب انك تقوم تاكل بالليل هذا اضطراب
من اضطرابات النوم نتكلم عن تصنيفات من
بعد ذلك هذا اضطراب في ناس تقوم بالليل
تاكل
وهو
واعينال
متلازمه الاكل الليلي حسنه يجوع وكذا في
ناس تقوم لا يقوم ياكل وهو ما يتذكر انه
ياكل او يتذكر شيء خفيف وقد ياكل من اشياء
ما يحبها عاده وتوصل لحالات اكستريم يعني
منتهيه جدا قد ياكل اكل
من الزباله اي شيء يطفي يده قد ياكله يقول
لك شو اكلت الشيء هذا وشفنا حالات هذا من
الاشياء يسمونها
يعني بجوار سوميا نوم باللاتيني يعني شاهد
تحدث في النوم خطر النوم اللي من ضمنها
مثلا المشي اثناء النوم يعبي النوم وهو
هذا واحد من المشاكل اللي تحدث مع زي مش
اثناء النوم في عده اضطرابات
تحدثني استوقفني سالفه هي انه في وحده من
الدراسات قلت انه المفترض انه كيس من جنس
مخت لف فما ناخذ واحد من افريقيا بواحد
عربي او واحد اسيا واحد عربي وهكذا فهل
فعلا يختلف النوم من ثقافه ثقافه هل تؤثر
يعني
ثقافات ولا العرق على جوده النوم وطريقه
النوم او اسلوب النوم نعم الثقافات
الدول تختلف في عادات النوع نبدا الجزء
الاول هذا اسهل يعني مثلا
في الكوكيجن يعني الخواجات بالذات في شمال
اوروبا وامريكا وحتى نيوزلندا واستراليا
موضوع القيلوله ما هو عندهم موجود
فعندهم نظام يعني تناموا متواصل
طول النهار ما هي موجوده هذا نظام القي
ولا عندهم ابدا لكن لما تيجي على حوض
البحر الابيض المتوسط مثلا اسبانيا يطلع
اسبانيا لما نحضن عندهم
يعملونها على اساس تنام يعني
ولما تيجي ايضا تنسحب على منطقتنا
الاسلاميه في منطقتنا الاسلاميه تاخذ بعد
ديني ايضا تاخد بعد الدين كتبنا عنها كثير
وتكلمنا عنها في التوصيات الوطنيه اللي من
الهيئه الصحه العامه والوقايه تكلمنا عن
موضوع القيلوله في التواصل
يعني المملكه الجنوبيه اللي كانوا مهاجرين
اسبان وكذا هناك عندهم نفس الشيء القيلوله
تيجي ما تم في اليابان عندهم القيلوله
في اليابان يعني عندهم في العرف في
التقاليد عادي انك مثلا انت في العمل
تغفولك شوي عادي حتى في العشاء يعني
بيتعشون يعني
عندهم فنعمل عادات تختلف وايضا العادات
بعدين في موضوع السهر يعني عامه في الغرب
مثلا خلاص يعني الانشطه تقفل الساعه خمسه
لانه اصلا كثير العام النقل العام يعني
والنقل العام يقفل مثلا الساعه كذا فلازم
يلحقوا يروح بيته وكذا يعني
خلاص يعني لكن في يعني خلاص ما عاد فيه
الاشياء لكن في ثقافات الناس المحلات
فاتحه الى كذا
جينا على موضوع الجنس يعني اغلب الدراسات
اللي قارنت الاجناس هي دراسات عاد تكون في
امريكا بصفه عامه يعني
خليط اجناس مختلفه يقولوا مثلا
بالحسبانك اللي هو من اصول مثلا اسبانيه
او مكسيكيه وكذا بالاسيويين بالاكل كان
امريكا الامريكان
وكذا
اختلاف بينهم مثلا
وجدوا انه مثلا اللي من اصول زي افريقيه
او مكسيكيه قد ناموسعات اقل قد يصورون
بالليل اكثر بعض الامراض عندهم تزيد مثلا
قطاع التنفس اثناء النوم قد يزداد عندهم
مقارنه بهذا طبعا ايضا لما تربط هذه
العوامل مع بعض يعني صعب انك ايضا تعزل
جنس وحده لانه عاده يصاحب هذه الامور في
كثير من هذا مثلا درجه تعليم اقل حتى لو
حاولوا السيطره عليها في تحليل واحصاء
البحث يعني يعني وظائفه قال داخل اقل
مناطق سكنيه اقل يعني امور كثيره تتدخل في
هذا الموضوع يعني وليس الجنس فقط قد يكون
في مثلا هذا الجنس راقي مثلا ومنصب كبير
واستاد جامعي وكذا ولكن قد يكون فيها يعني
يعني يغلب على بعض هذه الاجناس انه يكون
داخل اقل لكن وجدوا نعم اريد فروقات بدون
شك وعليها ابحاث كثيره طيب هل ممكن يؤثر
مثلا الجينات
انت ناس معينه وجنس معين على طريقه النوم
او اثر النوم بدون شك بدون شك يعني اولا
الجينات
تؤثر على مده النوم وتقع السائل
البيولوجيه نعم في طبعا زي ما بدك احنا
مثلا ساعات لكن هناك ما يسمون
باصحاب النوم القصير واصحاب النوم الطويل
الى مساعده اكثر ويحتاج مساعدات اكثر
والمقياس في النهايه هو النشاط بالنهار
والانتاجيه والاداء والتركيز والنفسيه
مرتاحه ولا في تاكد مزاج ولا في امراض
مصاحبه تفسر يعني النوم القصير يزعجوا شيء
بالنوم او يفسر النوم الطويل انه ما يشبع
النوم عنده مشاكل وهذه وجدوا انها علاقه
بالجينات حديثا يعني وجدوا الدراسه لو
يعني في التفصيل قليلا يعني في شيء قد
يكون يعني غريب
للمتابعين انه ذبابه الفاكهه سبحان الله
هي النموذج الامثل لنوم الانسان سبحان
الله كيف في الساعه البولوجيه وفي مده
النوم في كل شيء هي اكثر شيء يشابه
الانسان في النوم ذبابه الفاكهه فعملوا
تعديل
لنماذج حيوانيه من الذبابه
طويله وبعدين درسوا الجينات وجدوا انه
حوالي 118 جن مختلفه بلينا فهذا يدل انه
في عامل وراثي لكن الجيد في الامر ايضا
انه وجدوا انه البوابه ساعات طويله ما
اثرت على في النهايه الوفيات
جسمك يحتاج الشيء هذا لانه لما تبعد عن
عدم كفايه النوم لكن اذا كان جسمك يحتاج
هالشي ما في مشكله ايضا
الساعه البيولوجيه الساعه البيولوجيه
وجدوا انه مثلا اذا انت من النوع اللي ما
يجيك النوم بالليل بدري
وتحب تنام بالنهار وتكون متاخر ايضا له
علاقه بالجينات وهذا عامل وراثي قد ينتقل
من الاب والام الى
متنحيه يعني ما حدد الجيل بالضبط
لكن له علاقه بدون شك يعني في الموضوع
ايضا حتى من قد نفصل فيها لاحقا تذكر
الاحلام تذكر الاحلام عند البعض واسباب
كثيره لكن احد هالجينات
يعني عندهم جين انه عنده قابيل انه يتذكر
الحلم بشكل اكبر هناك امراض تصيب النوم
لها علاقه بالجينات ايضا يعني هي تصيب
النوم لها علاقه بجينات الشخص
يعني من الاشياء في المملكه ما يسمى
[موسيقى]
بمتلازمه او النوم الدوري او يسمونه
نوم الجميله هذا يعني مرض نادر ولكنه
عندنا حالات كثيره وعندنا احنا اول ناس
وصفنا عائله في المملكه هذا يجيهم
النوبه ينامون مثلا الاسبوع الاسابيع
ينامون ايه قد يقوم بس ياكل يعني يرجع
ينام ويكون عنده سلوك مختلف يكون عنده
ايضا عادات مختلفه وسلوكيات مختلفه وقد
يكون عنده عسلوكيات حتى غير مقبوله في
المجتمع ما تعودها الناس
جنسيه وكذا اشياء يعني
قد يكون يعني
فهذا مثلا له علاقه بالجين واحنا اشتغلنا
على اول الدراسات اللي حولت توصف الجين
يعني كانت من السعوديه هذه الدراسه طلعت
بعدها دراسات اخرى يعني
في عده اموال قد يكون لها علاقه بالجين
ايضا
يعني عندنا مثلا عائله
يتاخر كل يوم ساعه
ويوم دخل ساعه ساعه ساعه ساعه ساعه
يعني او
24 ساعه او في يعني
ساعه ويقلبوا ساعه ساعه ساعه فهذه لكن هذه
امراض نادره لكن يعني في نهايه الامر
العام الوراثي مهم في كل الامراض في كل
شيء واعتقد ان
الاشياء اللي لها علاقه جينيه ممكن تزداد
في
الشعوب اللي تتزاوج ما بين الاقارب اكثر
نعم هذا بدون شكل لذلك يعني كثير من يعني
عندنا احنا زملاء في علم الجينات في مختلف
يعني المراكز العلميه البحثيه في المملكه
يعني هم من ناس متميزين على مستوى العالم
لانه الحلت عنا كثير يعني اليهود تزاوج
يعني ابناء العمومه وكذا
يزيد من ظهور الحالات اللي هي يعني تكون
لها علاقه بالجينات
طب هل للنوم انواع ولا هو شكله واحد
يعني ما اعرف انواع من ناحيه يعني ناحيه
هو هو لو تكلمنا مثلا على مراحل النوم من
ناحيه التحليليه
النوم نعم في له مراحل يعني انه من ناحيه
تخطيط من ناحيه علميه تخطيط في المختبر
يعني في المختبر احنا نخطط عده وظائف في
الجسم ينام الشخص وعلى ضوء هذه المعلومات
نصنف النوم فهذا تصنيف علمي
ما يعني بالضروره انه هذا التصنيف اللي
الله خالقه في الانسان في النوم هذا على
حد علمنا احنا اللي وصلنا له الان يعني
نخطط كهرباء الدماغ مخطط العضلات مخطط
القلب خط
التنفس مخطط الاكسجين الكربون خطتها وعلى
ضوء هذه الامور المصنف النوع الى اربع
مراحل
وفي التصنيف الكبير مرحلتين مرحله غير
الاحلام والاحلام غير الاحلام ثلاث مراحل
المرحله الاولى حوالي 5% من النوم تشكل
انسان طبيعي البالغ
هي المرحله انتقاليه بين مراحل النوم
مختلفه بعدين المرحله الثانيه تشكل اغلب
النوم 45 55 بالمئه والمقعد حوالي 20% هذا
الانسان البالغ طبعا في الاطفال قد تختلف
النسب هذه البالغ لاغلب انسان يكون في
حياته هو بالغ وبعدين تيجي الاحلام حوالي
25 بالمئه كل مرحله مهمه جدا
تمر هذه الاربع دورات بدورات المراحل
فالانسان سبع ثمان ساعات قد يمر بخمس الى
ثمان دورات من النوم
في البدايه تكون النوم العميق اكثر وفي
النهايه يكون الاحلام اكثر تتبع ايقاع
يومي الاحلام البيولوجيه لكن لو كان شخص
محبوب منها قطتها في وقت مبكر يعني قطعتين
في مرحله الاحلام
بعكس مراحل اخرى مراحل الاخرى يقل الضعف
تقل دقات القلب التنفسكم منضبط في الاحلام
سبحان الله تختلف الامور
دقات القلب
يزيد نشاط الاستنباتاتيكي اللي هو حق
التوتر والقلق
التنفس يكون استهلاك الدماغ للاكسجين
والجلوكوز اعلى من اليقظه نشاط الدماغ
اعلى من اليقظه وهذه كلها مراحل لها وظائف
مهمه جدا يعني كل مرحله لها وظائف مهمه
لابد ان يدخل الشخص
وبعدين نرجع للوظائف
اذا اخذنا الانماط النوم يعني هل هو احنا
نسميه
احادي
الفتره او النمط او باي فيزك ثنائي النمط
احادي النمط اللي هو نوم متواصل يعني واحد
ينام بالليل نومه واحده الى وخلاص هذا
احادي النمط اكثر الابحاث انه هو في
الغابه
فيه اللي هو ثنائي النمط يعني واحد ينام
بالليل وبعدين ياخذ له قيلوله بالنهار
يعني من الابحاث الموجوده الى الان واللي
حتى في المنطقه حملات يعني من ناحيه
تاثيرات الصحيه ما في فرق بين احادي النمط
وثنائي النمط
لكن ما يسمى بهذا
اللي هو متعدد هذا مظله او ما يمكن اقول
هذا ارتبط بامراض يعني ما نقدر نقول هو
السبب لكن يصاحب الاشخاص اللي عندهم
اكثر من نوبه نوم تجيه ثلاث اربع خلال 24
ساعه يكون عندهم امراض اخرى عضويه
انه يكون السبب لكنه في السوشيال في
ارتباط بينهم عاده مثل ايش السكري امراض
القلب تصلب الشرايين من الجلطات الاورام
كثير من الامور هذه الخلف كثير من هذه
الامور تكون تزداد عندهم بالامور اللي
كانت تهمني ايضا انه قضيه انه حل الشخص
اذا
استيقظ بالليل من صلاه الليل مثلا اللي هو
شيء صحي ولا لا طبعا ويعني في الحديث انه
يعني واحد ما ينام قبل صلاه العشاء ما
تكون حديث صحيح وايضا يكره الحديث بعد
صلاه العشاء
وبعدين يعني في هدنه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم انه كان يعني ينام مثلا يقوم يصلي
وينام بعدين صرت قبل
بعض الابحاث الغربيه اللي ما لها علاقه
بالمسلمين تشير لانه قد يكون هذا النمط
صحي ايضا انك تقوم بالليل لفتره طبعا
الناس غير مسلمين كان يستيقظ الاسباب
مختلفه لكن قد يكون صحي انك تستيقظ لفتره
الفتره هذه قد تكون ساعه اكون مثلا ساعه
اقل من ساعه وتوجع تنام مره ثانيه قد يكون
بعضهم الاسباب مختلفه يستيقظ يرجع ينام
وبعدين بعد الفجر المفروض يبدا اليوم بعد
صلاه الفجر انه حتى في الابحاث وغير
المسلمين اللي عملوها وجدوا انه تعريف
بقياس التغيرات الهرمونات اللي تحدث
الساعه البيولوجيه تبدا مع الفجر مع الدون
الفجر وليس شروق الشمس
قد تبدا مع الدهون يعني مع الفجر
حتى واذا ما تعرضت انا للشمس لاني في غرفه
مغلقه يعني هو تبدا مع الفجر حتى لو واحد
ما تعرض للضوء يفرز الهرمون وقته لكن لو
قاعد في فتره في جزء مظلم ولا يلخبط مع
الفتره تتغير يعني ما تتغير من اول ليله
قد تستمع حتى لو في هذا يستمر الافراز
بنفس النظام لكن بعد فتره عده ايام اذا
مارس يعني السلوكيات الخاطئه او نمط
الحياه الخاطئ قد انها تبدا تتغير الساعه
البيولوجيه
هل علميا فيه
اي اثر على نومه المغرب
يعني هذا سؤال صعب
لانه يرجع للساعه البيولوجيه
يعني اذا شخص متعود من يستيقظ الفجر
خلينا نقول ايام ايام هذه الشتاء يعني في
الرياض مثلا يعني نقول مثلا يكون الساعه
مثلا
واربعين صلاه الفجر ويبدا يومه هذا شخص
مستيقظ من الصباح الباكر يعني حتى احنا
وضعنا التوصيات الوطنيه تكلمنا عن الناس
اللي يستقدون طبيعي المفروض هذا الطبيعي
قلنا انه ياخذ قيلوله حوالي وقت الظهر
النون تايم يعني قبلها بعدها نص ساعه
انا ممكن اجي اطبق هالنظام اقول له خذ
قيلوله الساعه 12 الظهر على واحد اصلا هو
يصحى الساعه 11
لذلك اذا جينا نقول المغرب اذا اخذ قيلوله
متى يقوم ومتى ينام واحد مثلا يصحى الساعه
11 الصبح
وهو اصلا ما ينام للساعه مثلا خلنا نقول
مثلا الساعه 3:00 الفجر
قد تكون قيلوله هذه قيلوله نص ساعه المغرب
فالناس ما هم سواسه ما هم يعني قالب واحد
مسطره واحده على الجميع ما يمكن اني اجي
لكن اغلب الناس اللي يصحون الصباح نقول
لهم هذا مو جيد في السابق كان هذا
الطبيعي هذا النوع يعني حق الناس انه
الناس تصعب هذه كلهم الاعمالهم يعني
حتى ابائنا واجدادنا
ابوي مثلا وجدي كان اوكي لا لا
دائما يعني ما عمري نمت في وقت المغرب قبل
المغرب الا اقوم وانا متنكد
هو شو بصفه عامه يعني يعني احنا ما سمعنا
انصح بالنوم
يعني يكون القيلوله في وقت الظهر قبل او
بعد ما ينصح بالنوم بعدها لانه النوم
بعدها هياخذ بالليل بدون شك يؤثر على جوده
امك بالليل بدون شك لكن هل في ابحاث تقول
مؤكده وابحاث القصيره تقول لك نومه المغرب
هذه للي مثلا بياخروا نومه اصلا ما ينام
الا الساعه 3:00 الفجر بياخذ له غفوه انه
تؤثر على جوده نومه لا ما في على اساس
تعرف
العلميه يعني طيب بالنسبه
للحين اخذنا الفروقات بين الناس بين الدول
بين الاجناس
في فرق بين الرجل والمراه
يعني هل يختلف النوم عندهم في الاغلب لا
يختلف لا يختلف لكن
في الدراسات قد تكون المراه بالذات في سن
الولاده والحمل قد تكون تنام ساعه اقل او
كذا لانها عاده تعتني بالاطفال حتى في
الغابه الاطفال اكثر من الرجل فقد تكون
تنام ساعه اقل لكن بصفه عامه في النوم
متشابه
يختلف تختلف المراه عن الرجل في بعض
التغيرات الفسيولوجيه مثلا في سن ما قبل
توقف الطمس
سن الهرمونات الانثويه ما زالت موجوده
يكون النوم يعني بصفه عامه جيد لكنه يتاثر
بفتره الطمس
فتره الطمس قد يكون
دور الشهريه قد يكون يتاثر النوم بشكل
كبير من نواحي كثيره قد يضطرب النوم
قد قلق بعض المجلس زياده في النعاس
شخير حتى اتكلمنا عنها هذا نوم الجميل
اللي هو متلازمه اللي عندهم مشكله هذه من
البنات يصير عندهم فتره الدوره الشهريه
يعني وايضا فتره الحمل تغيرات هذه طبعا ما
تحجز للرجل في البدايات يزيد عندهم النعاس
في الثلث الاول من الحامل يزيد عندهم
احيانا بعدين بده يصير عندهم التبول
يصحيهم بالليل اكثر من مره في الثلث
الشخير والاختناق اثناء النوم هذه خاصه
فيهم اذا توقفت الدوره الشهريه
احنا لما جينا نتكلم ونكتب في الموضوع هذا
كان وش افضل كلمه نجيبها يعني جميله
فتوجدنا الطمس اتذكر كان احد
الاطباء معنا من سوريا وكان جاي متدرب
ودارس الطب في سوريا بالعربي فقلت له
اعطني افضل كلمه ما ابغى اقول انا يعني
كذا ما ادري وش اقول الكلمه اللي مناسبه
وتكون العلميه وجميله يعني عطاني الكلمه
ابدا
ما عرفناه لان اتكلم عنها كتبنا عنها كثير
هذه الامور طيب
اللي يحصل في دوله
طبيعي مثلا
لما نيجي بعدين بعد توقف الدوره الشهريه
تتخيل الامور عند السيده تبدا تدخل في
مشاكل طلبات نوم تكون عندك اكثر في
البدايه مثلا رجل عنده انقطاع التنفس
اثناء النوم ومن علاماته الشخصيه
والاختناق الليل وهذا مضاعفات ومو شائع
جدا يحتاج نغطيه شائع جدا اعلى عند الرجل
اعلى عند الرجل منه عند السيده اكثر منه
السيدات تقريبا ضعف الى ضعفين ونصف اصابه
السيدات لانه مجرى التنفس العلوي عند
الرجال توكيلته تختلف عن المراه فهو اكثر
قابليه للانسداد لكن بعد توقف الدوره
الشهريه او الطمس تبدا المراه تكون نفس
شيوعه عندك رجل تدخل نفس المشكله ايضا
انقطاع التنفس عند السيدات في سن اصغر
يحدث مراحل الاحلام اكثر وهذا اضطراب قد
انت يخلف عنه قطاع التنفس كل مراحل يقطع
في كل المراحل
عند السيدات اعلى
هذا عند السيدات اعلى من الرجال ومع كبار
السنة لكن السيدات اعلى قد يكون عند
السيدات اعلى منشطنه هو مرض اكثر قد يكون
هم يجون الاطباء يعانون منه اكثر احساسهم
في اكثر
اللي يوصى فيه في الغرب انه درجه الحراره
للنوم للجميع رجال ونساء التوصيات هذه
حوالي 18 ل 20 درجه
في غرفه الهذا لكن انا بحثت هذا الموضوع
وقالت الدراسات في الغرب مع الدراسات
العملاء في مناطق الدافع زي منطقه
انه اغلب في الدراسه يعني الدراسات
منطقتنا قد تشير لانه درجه الحراره على
حوالي 24 درجه هذه درجه الحراره
قد تكون مناسبه للنوم لانه الناس عندنا
عشرين 18 يحس بالبلد لا يستطيع ينام
فاغلب الدراسات عندنا على الاقل في
المنطقه تقول يمكن 24 درجه في غرفه النوم
هذا للرجال والنساء قد تكون دراسه لكن هذا
المجمل والتوصيات يعني عاده هذه الغرفه
درجه حراره المناسبه انه البروده الشديده
تؤثر على جوده النوم والحراره تؤثر على
جوده النوم ايضا وهلا الطقس والمناخ يؤثر
على
الناس التي تعيش في هذه يعني فتره النوم
جوده النوم يختلف من يعني طبعا هذا ما
ينطبق علينا مثلا في البال لانه احنا مثلا
لا في بيوت وتدفئه وكذا لكن درسوا الاشخاص
بالذات مثلا القطب الجنوبي لانه في كثير
من المراكز البحثيه في القطب الجنوبي كثير
مثلا في المناطق البارده كان الجو بارد
جدا تقل الاحلام
تقل الاحلام في البدايه ويزيد افراز بعض
الهمزه ويزداد افرازوا في الليل لانه
هرمون التوتر
لذلك مع زياده في الصباح تحدث كثير من
الجلطات فوق الصباح
لكن مع التعود وجدوا انه بعد فتره متابعه
بدو يتاقلمون مع جوده النوم ايضا تتسوم
على الجو البارد جدا بدون شك انه الجو
البارد والجو الحاوي يؤثر على جوده النوم
عند الاشخاص لكن احنا الحمد لله يعني تكون
داخلي والجو معتدل وكذا يعني ما في لكن
اذا كانت حراره بارده جدا نعم قد يؤثر على
جوده النوم الفصول مهمه جدا انا كان عندي
اهتمام في هذا الموضوع ايضا وفي ابحاث
فصول السنه لانه انا مثلا كان من تفكيري
لما انا عندي اهتمام في موضوع مثلا
النوم في الثقافه الاسلاميه ونكتب عليه
بالمناسبه من ناحيه علميه بالتجاوز يعني
اكتب فيه احاول اتجرد من العاطفه انا لا
ابحث عن الاعجاز لان الاشياء عندي معجزه
انا ابحث عشان افهم
عشان افهم وقد يعطيني نظريات بحثيه
فيعني احنا لما نقوم بالصيف بدري هل احنا
نحتاج ساعات نوم اقل
فوجدوا في دراسه مثلا في اليابان دراسه
انه ما عنده دوامهم وجدوا يناموا
وجدوا حتى في الدراسات لعل المجتمعات
الاوليه هذه
انهم في فصل الشتاء قالوا
وما عندهم صلاه يقومون لها هذا يقول
السؤال الاخر هل فصل الشتاء نحتاج ساعات
نوم اكثر ما عندي اجابه للسؤال لكنه هذا
كنت افكر فيه يعني في الصين طبعا احنا
منطقه معتدله يعني نتكلم على المناطق اللي
هي في الشمال لانهم طويل جدا لا اتكلم على
البشريه عاشت فيها من البدايه لمنطقتنا
يعني هذا منطقه الهلال الخصيب التغيرات
المعقوله في الصيف والشتاء يعني قد يكون
ساعه ساعه ونص فقد يكون نحتاج نوم اكثر في
الشتاء قد يكون هذا وارد
[موسيقى]
طيب بالنسبه لاخر شيء على
الجنس او الازواج هل النوم جوده النوم تقل
او تزيد اذا كان الزوجين ينامون مع بعض هم
بصفه عامه وجدوا انه المتزوجين نوعهم افضل
نومهم افضل نعم جوده النوم افضل النشاط
افضل امراض اقل
النفسيه افضل كل الامور افضل
للزوجين اذا كان الزوجين ما عندهم امراض
فنومهم يعني في نفس السرير ما يخسر على
جوده النوم لكن اذا كان احد عندهم مثلا
شخيل انقطاع في التنفس انه مع قطاع التنفس
لما يبدا النفس يقطع ويبدا يكون في فزه
يفز ويهز السريع احيانا وجد انه اذا
عالجوا المصاب نوم الشخص الاخر يتحسن ب 18
وعشرين بالمئه انه يزعجه هذا لكنه كنوم
الزوجين مع بعض لا بالعكس يعني ما في
تاثير ابدا ده كانهم طبيعي طيب وش العوامل
التي تؤثر على ان الانسان يكون صباحي او
مسائي فتلقى في ناس يقول لك انا انسان
صباح يعني انا نشاطي كله يبدا في الصباح
فاحب يعني يعني
في عده عوامل عمل جيني مهم جدا العامل
الوراثي
العام الاخر السن يعني المراهقين وفي
بدايه المثل العشرينات قد يكون بعض الشباب
يعني
عشان كذا في الاجازات يسهون وهذا
النقطه الاخرى نمط الحياه اللي يمارس
الشخص يعني اذا هو يمارس نمط حيائي يساعده
على اذا كان الانشطه الاجتماعيه والانشطه
الاخرى حتزيد بالليل هيتحول الى انسان
مسائي بدون شك راح يروح مثلا
ويشرب قهوه وكافيه وكذا بالليل حيتحول فهي
يعني ثلاثه عوامل تتداخل مع بعضها لكن
وجدوا في الابحاث فروقات بين الصباحيين
والمسائيين متى الصباح وجدوا انه منجز
اكثر
اجتماعي اكثر
نفسيته افضل
المساء يوجد عنده امور بعكس الشخص هذا مع
انه قد يكون منجز وكذا في امور معينه لكن
بصفه عامه يعني احنا لما نقول الابحاث ما
نقيس شخص بمفرده
الفين مثلا
كل واحد لازم يكون منها النوعيه لكن وجدوا
انه الشخص الصباحي انجاز اكثر وامورك اكثر
يعني
في وحده من مقالات من كتبتها يعني هنا
استغربت انه موعد او الموسم اللي ولد فيه
الانسان يؤثر على انه يكون صباح والمسائي
صحيح هذا يعني كان بعض الدراسات وعلى يعني
التعرض لضوء القمر هذه دراسات يعني اوليه
يعني قد يكون مثلا ضوء القمر
يعتقد انه قد يؤثر والمد والجهاز قد يؤثر
حتى يؤثر على نشاط
الزلازل اللي حاصل الله يحفظ الجميع يعني
هذه كلها عوامل يعني انا اكتب احيانا من
باب انه في بحث
ظهر وانه في مجله مرموقه وبحث محكم لكن
هذه افكار قد تكون اكثر هي اطروحات بحثيه
انه في هذا قد يحتاج له بحث اكثر
فصحيح الفصول قد يكون عليها تاثيرات انه
الشخص هذا مثلا يكون نهاري يكون ليلي في
بعض الدلائل لكنها نعطي المشاهده والمتابع
معلومه جاده فيه هناك لكن يحتاج الى توثيق
اكثر قصدي انه ممكن مو بالضروره اني انا
اكون مسائي لعاداتي سلوكياتي
مهم جدا العامل الجيني مهم
العوامل الخارجيه مهمه قد يكون من ضمنها
هذا يعني الفصول لكنها يعني لا بد من
تحديدها يعني هو طبعا العلم يعني علم واسع
وعلم طب النوم ايضا بالذات اتكلمنا عنه
والساعه البيولوجيه علم نسبيا جديد يعني
وعلم يتوسع كل يوم وكل يوم يظهر ارتباطه
بالامراض الاخرى واهميته
هل اقدر اعرف اذا انا جينيا كيف اقدر احدد
اني انا صباح
اقدر لا يعني اللي يقول مثلا انه مثلا في
اخوان اكثر واحد عنده نفس المشكله
مثلا اذا كان والده او والدته كان عندهم
نفس المشكله في العائله في كثير عندهم نفس
المشكله يعني هو كل فتره تطلع ابحاث تعرف
بعض الجين لانه في جينات يسمونها
جينات الساعه البيولوجيه في عده جينات
نشاطاتها تختلف عند عدد من اكتشف يعني
جينات جديده وهذه لها نشاطات وقد يكون
نشاطها تنشط عند بعض الناس بالليل وبعضهم
تنشط بالنهال ممكن تقاس لكن عاده تقاس
للامور البحثيه لكن اللي عنده مثلا حتى
يجيناتهم هذا القبيله يستطيع انه يعدل
نومه يستطيع يعدل في علاج يعني علاج في ان
يكون سلوكي ويعني تعديل الضوء مع بعض
الادويه لكن تعديل الضوء ونمط الحياه يعني
هو الاساس
ويجيني كثير من المرضى يعني بهذه المشكله
ويتحسن عاده اكثر ناس يتحسنون عندي طلاب
الطب والاطباء لانهم فاهمين ايش تقول لهم
وعندهم يعني هو الطب بصفه عامه شبيه
بالعسكريه في الالتزام
عنده المعلومه هو يعني استوعبوا شو بالضبط
ما هو يعني نقسم في الاخرين لكن هو فاهم
الفيزيولوجيه حقت الجسم كيف تحدث ويعرف
انه ما حينجح اذا ما التزم هالامور لكن
اللي يصعب على البقيه يلتزم معك في
الاسبوع في ايام الاسبوع اذا جت نهايه
الاسبوع ما يستطيع يلتزم لازم يطلع مع
اصحابه يسهل او مع العائله او ما يقلب
نومه
الجسم يحبذبه النوم هذا فيرجع عندك وعاده
اغلب العلاجات سلوكيه ولا فيها سلوكيه
دوائيه في دوائيه لكن في الاساس سلوكيه
يعني هو التعرض للضوء اهم شيء الضوء القوي
في النهار توقيته نحدده مع الشخص
والاضاءه الخافته بالليل تجنب الاجهزه
اللوحيه بالليل انظمه عيد لك والاستيقاظ
قد نعطي مثلا في البدايه بالليل مثلا
لتقديم الساعه البيولوجيه الهدف تقديم
الساعه البيولوجيه لمده محدوده فقط وعمل
مساعد اهم شيء الضوء والالتزام بنفس
النظام في ايام الاسبوع ونهايه الاسبوع
وتجنب الغفوات بقدر الامكان بالنها لانه
جسمه يحب النوم بالنهار اذا نام بالنهار
ما تكون يعني غفوه قصيره يسحب لانه صعب
عاده لما نقول غفوه لقيلوله نتكلم عن كم
حطيناها في التوصيات انها ما زد عن نصف
ساعه ما تزيد نصف ساعه والحصول على ساعات
نوم كافيه بالليل هذا الصحي هذا الصحي
اللي قناه نتحدث عن اهميه النوم
يعني النوم وظيفه وانا اقول لهم النوم
وظيفه وفي احد المرات طلب مني اني اكتب
خطاب رساله الى طفل عن النوم من زمان من
سنوات عديده يعني الطلاب مدير التعليم او
شيء قلنا لهم انه العقل السليم في النوم
السليم
في النوم السليم تكلمنا عنه هو مثلث الصحه
اللي يعرفون الناس من ضلعين ويركزون عليها
الغذاء الصحي والتمارين الرياضيه الضلع
الثالث واللي قد يكون اهم النوم
لانه بدون نوم صحي لا يمكن تشتغل الضلع
الاخرين في النوم الصحي مهم والنوم الصحي
ليس فقط في جوده النوم ولكن في مده النوم
وتوقيت النوم اغلب الابحاث والتوصيات تقول
سابع لثمان ساعات او سبع لتسع ساعات من
النوم الليلي الليلي مهمه جدا لانه النوم
النهاري في اغلب الاحيان ما يكون بجوده
النوم الليلي الا يكون في حتى لو حاولنا
نخلق البيئه ما تقلق البيئه البيئه تؤثر
عليك كثير من الازعاج من الاضاءه من
الالتزامات
وشهميه النوم طبعا في امور واضحه للناس في
اهميه النوم يعني الامور الواضحه تعكو
بالمزاج عدم التركيز زياده النعاس
الاكتئاب قد يكون القلق والتوتر مثبت ايضا
الاداء الاكاديمي لكل المراحل العمريه حتى
لو نص ساعه وهذا وجدنا حتى عندنا في
الطلاب اكاديمي يتاثر حتى نصف ساعه تفقد
كثير هذه الامور قد تكون واضحه من النوم
يعني الاطفال مثلا نص ساعه زياده
وابحث عالميه
في امور اخرى الان كل ما اكتب في العلم
اشياء مهمه انه النوم هذا وظيفه وليست
يعني بس سويتش ممكن ان استغنى عنه
في وظائف تحدث خلال النوم لو بدل انا
كوننا طلعنا من جائحه كورونا في الجهاز
المناعي الجهاز المناعي مهم جدا لكفاءه
نوم كافيه وهذا نعرفه
يعني وجدوا انه يعني في التجارب حتى
المخبريه في المختبر اذا
قللوا نفس العينه خلوهم ينامون مثلا ساعات
وبعدين ساعات اقل لما ينام كون احتمال
اصابتهم بالفيروس اعلى بثلاث اضعاف وجدوا
حتى ايام كورونا
انه اللقاح الليمون ساعات اقل استجابكم
المناعيه كانت اقل الاستجابه المناعيه
للقاح كانت اقل بالاجسام المضاده لنهار
اقل فهو مهم للخلايا المناعيه للجينات
التي تهتم بالمناعه فهو مهم جدا للمناعه
النوم ايضا مهم جدا للجهاز الدوري والقلب
يعني بصفه عامه دقات القلب تقل والضغط تقل
خلال
يقلب حوالي اكثر من عشره بالمياه اذا كان
يزيد هذا يؤثر نقص النوم الان ساعات النوم
في جميع الاعمار ثبت انه يزيد خطر الاصابه
بضغط الدم وامراض القلب لقد تصلب الشرايين
كذا ايضا خطا صلب الشرايين الدماغ ايضا
هناك خطوره ايضا في الاصابه بالهذا ايضا
مقاومه الجسم للانسولين
يعني السكري يعني سمنه يعني تشمع في الكبد
يعني امور كثيره يعني ممكن تصاب بالسمنه
او بالسكري لكله ساعات
ايضا قلت ساعات النوم
تزيد افراز هرمون الجريلين هرمون الجوع في
هرمون اللبتين
يعرف انه في الليل اذا جاء يصير عنده شهيه
يعني هذا يطلب الاشياء اللي السكريات
نشويات اللي تسمن هذا ما يطلب اكل مثلا
صحي لسى وليه ماشي سلطه
هي الاشياء اللي تسمى يعني فيزيد وزنه
مرتبه حتى عنا دراسات محليه عملوها في
الزملاء وجدوا انه مثلا طلاب الثانويه
اليوم
السمنه اعلى
ايضا النوم مهم للنمو هرمون النمو يفرز في
ممنوع العميق نوع مقعد هذا ما يتبعه اي
وقت يدخل شخص من النوم العميق
[موسيقى]
ليس فقط للاطفال المهم حتى للكبار يصلح
الخلايا المعطوبه
النوم مهم للتخلص من خلايا السرطانيه يطلع
في الجسم الخلايا الوطنيه يهاجمها الجهاز
المناعي
اللي لذلك قله النوم ربطت ببعض الاورام
الخبيثه مثلا
الثدي عند السيدات القولون عند الرجال
كثير من الامراض ربطت بنقص النوم ايضا ربط
حديثا ايضا نقص النوم
بالخرف عند كبار السن عدم انتظام وقت
النوم عند كبار السن تستحق مثلا عدم او
نقص ساعات النوم
بالخرف بالخرف
وحتى في الشباب الصغار لكن وجدوا التغيرات
وجدوا في النماذج الحيوانيه للابحاث
انه الصرف النفايات الخلويه الخلايا
الدماغيه يعني تشتغل طول اليوم
يصير فيها صرف الانتاج
النفايات النفايات تتجمع وتكون البروتينات
اللي اذا تجمعت تؤدي الى الاصابه
بالزهايمر اللي منها
تصرف في النوم العميق في الجهاز الانفاوي
الجهاز الليمفاوي تصرف فمهم الدخول في
النوم العميق حتى تصرف هذه
يعني
قد يكون شيء بشيء يذكر انا عندي اهتمام
انا في قضيه
الاسلامي في النوم وجدوا ان النوم على
الجنبين
يزيد الصرف
الخلايا في الجهاز الانفاوي والنوم على
البطن يوقفه تماما
احاول افهم وليس ولا ابحث عن الاعجاز عندي
معجز في القران والسنه معجز ما يحتاج لكن
انا ابحث عشان افهم انتبه على الظاهر
على الظهر وسط كان بين الاثنين لكن على
جنبين كان افضل شيء ايضا مهم للذاكره
والذاكره هذه يفصل فيها الموضوع يعني في
السابق كنا نعتقد انه نوم العميق ومهم
للذاكره
لانه يعني في مراكز في الدماغ في مركز
للداخل القصير وسمى الحسين والفص الجبهه
الذاكره طويله الامد تنقل المعلومات في
النوم من الحسين الفصل الجبهي بعدين
اكتشفنا انه الاحلام ايضا مهمه في هذا
الموضوع ليس فقط حتى الاحلام مهمه ايضا
للذاكره مهمه جدا للذاكره تساعد في نقل
المعلومات طبعا الذاكره نوعين نوعين
تحفظنا ونوع عفوا هذا النوع يعني في نصوص
او شيء ونوع زي مثلا واحد يتعلم شلون يسوق
السيكل مثلا دراجه وكذا هذا هذه الاحلام
مهمه له لانه انا احتمتها الموضوع بحث فيه
لاني وجدت
هذا الموضوع اخر يعني لكن كان عندنا
احتمال في هذه القضيه ايضا وجد من الاحلام
مهمه سبحان الله شبهوها بالكمبيوتر يعني
هذا بالرام لما يتعبى لازم انك انت تقفل
الجهاز عشان يشيل اللي فيه وجدوا انه
الحسين اللي ذاكر القصيره
[موسيقى]
اذا نمت يفضى فيقوم الصبح فاضي
في الاحلام فتوح الاشياء هذه وتنتهي تروح
وايضا
الالتقاءات الخلايا العصبيه ايضا تتشبع
وبعدين وتنتفخ بعدين تنتقل يعني مره اخرى
مع النوم الاحلام ايضا مهمه للتخلص من
المشاعر السيئه يعني الواحد يصير عندهم
ضغوطات طول اليوم وقد مشاعر الله يقوم
الصبح كانه شيء السابق موجود جزء كثير من
هذا يحدث في الاحلام فالاحلام يعني برغم
انه نشاط اعلى وكذا مهمه جدا تصفيه الدهن
لاشياء كثيره فمهم الشخص ياخذ كفايته من
كل مره هذا الشيء اللي نعرفها طبعا
افراسهمات وكل يوم يتكشف شيء جديد يعني
طبعا هذا مؤتهم العلمي الا قليله كل ما
جديد لكن هناك وظائف للنوم وظائف للقضاء
ما يمكن خلط الاثنين مع بعض فهل الحين على
الذاكره
هي تنتقل من الذاكره القصيره في وقت النوم
الى الذاكره طويله ولا نعم تنقل
وتعزز واسترجاعها اسهل
حتى وجدوا في احد الابحاث لانه ايضا احنا
اشتغلنا على موضوع الاداء الاكاديمي
والطلاب وجدوا في احد الابحاث انه اذا انت
نام ليله الامتحان ساعات قصيره وما تدخل
ما توصل الاحلام لانه الاحلام
الطبيعي اتزيد عنده الاحلام في نهايه
النوم عشان كذا الواحد لو الصبح قال الاخ
نص ساعه هنام زياده او شيء وكان قلق انه
ما راح الدوام او مثلا ما قام صلى او شيء
يحسنوا احلام تزداد في نهايه النوم هذا
اذا موضوع الانقطاع التنفس قد يكون مهم
بالحديث
وجدوا انه ادائهم اسوا اللي ناموا ساعات
اقل ليله الامتحان لانه قد يكون ما وصل
مرحله الاحلام
مهمه
للقدره على استرجاع المعلومه ايضا النوم
مو بسينا ايضا سرعه الاسترجاع في الامتحان
تبغى تسترجع الذاكره بشكل سريع تسترجع
المعلومه
لازم تكون وايضا في الفعل مهمه جدا يعني
يعني اللي يكون محروم من النوم
ردت فعله بطيئه شكل الحوادث اعلى حوادث
اعلى اللي ينام اقل من خمس ساعات وجدوا
انه الحوادق ثمانيه اضعاف
خمسه الى مثلا سبع ساعات ثلاثه اضعاف
فتردت الفعل تكون افضل ويعتقد انه بعد
الحوادث التي مثلا
يعتقد انه قد يكون الشخص اللي هذا ما نام
بشكل جيد ما اتخذ القرار الصحيح اذا كنت
محروم من النوم قد تكون معلومه عندك لكن
ما تتاخذ القرار الصحيح
وايضا الحرمان من النوم هذه نقطه مهمه بعض
ناس اعتقد انه بس في ايام الاسبوع بعوض في
نهايه الاسبوع هذه عليها ابحاث ما تعوض في
نهايه الاسبوع لانك ساعه وحده قد يحتاج لك
اسبوع من النوم الطبيعي عشان تعوضها نقص
ساعه النوم قد يصل بعض الى درجه انه
المخمور يعني اللي هو ماخذ كحوليات درجه
الممنوع الوقود السياره فيه ايضا القيلوله
ما تعوض عن عدم النوم كفايه بالليل الواحد
اذا نعم نشاط قد يعطيه شعور خادع انه تحسن
لكن لا ما وجد وجد ايضا انه التعويض في
الويكند ما يقلل من الخطا الاصابه الدم من
الحرمان من النوم
لذلك احنا نشرنا بحث عام 2018
ورقه علميه اسمها انصف
النوم عدم الكافي متلازمه طبعا الكافي
وهذا في تصنيف النوم العالمي تعريف عدم
النوم الكافي انك تضع بيئه انه كل شيء
هل حان الوقت لتصنيفه احد الامراض
الرئيسيه غير المعديه لانه عندها مقاطع
رئيسيه معديه وغير معديه من غير معديه
مثلا زي اللي مدخنين مثلا ضغط الدم امراض
القلب بالسرطان فقلنا انه كل الشروط التي
تستخدم
لتصنيف الامراض غير معديه الرئيسيه تنطبق
على الحلمه من النوم تنطبق عليه يعني
الحكمه من النوم قد يصنف كاحد الامراض
كمرض
هذا انه لانك انت اذا حبيت بها المشكله
انت حددت من كثير من الامراض زين لما
اعالجوا السكري انا الان اقل من فشل الكلى
من جلطات القلب والدماغ من مشاكل مختلفه
من رتل الاعضاء كثير من الامور من الاشياء
كثيره اذا حلصت الناس انه ثقافه انه يا
جماعه النوم مهم جدا بذات الاطفال وكذا
انه انا امنع كثير من الامراض العضويه ليس
فقط النفسيه ولا السلوكيه ولا الاداء
هذه نقطه يعني مهمه جدا طبعا رفعنا وصل
عليها رده فعل لكن ما سووا شيء يحكي يعني
لما نتكلم عن النوم للانسان طبيعي نتكلم
من سته ساعات من البالغ البالغ من سبع
ساعات والكبير
اطفال مواليد يحتاجها 18 ساعه 21 ساعه 21
ساعه المواليد
مثلا الطفل في الابتدائيه قد يحتاج الى 11
ساعه نوم
عشر سنوات حوالي عشر ساعات نوم
فالطفل الابتدائيه اذا نام سبع ساعات
يعتبر
قليل ويؤثر على صحته ومؤثر على صحته ممكن
انه يعني حتى تغيرات في الضغط وكذا طبعا
جسمه ما زال يعني يزيل يعني يتحمل الامور
مزيل الكبير
وانهم لما تقول اني ياثر على الذاكره على
المدى القصير ولا يعني اقدر ياثر على اللي
بكره وبعده ولا يؤثر على المدى البعيد
يؤثر على كل الحالتين يؤثر على تخزين
المعلومه الجديده اللي واحد اكتسبها في
اليوم على تخزينها واسترجاعها مره اخرى
ويؤثر على المدى الطويل زي ما ذكرنا انه
التغيرات والصنف النفايات الخلويه
والتغيرات
وبروتين تاو وكذا قد تتجمع بالذات عندهم
قابليه جينيه لهذه المشكله لذلك انا اذا
عملت مثلا تخطيط كبار السن عنده مشكله انه
احتجبتها اذا وجدته يدخل في النوم العميق
وجدت الكبيره يدخل في النوم العميق بشكل
انبسط يعني اقول الحمد لله ان شاء الله
انه يعني امور طيبه ان شاء الله لانه كبير
يقل النوم العميق مع التقدم العمر
اشرت كذا مره على التوصيات الوطنيه تقدر
تعطيني وش التوصيات يعني
للسعوديين يعني واحنا اولا في التوصيات
قسمنا الى اطفال والى كبار بالغين
وراجعنا الابحاث التي نشرت على مده النوم
والصحه الصحه بصفه عامه
لدراسه هذا جميع الامراض العضويه والنفسيه
وغيره والاداء الاكاديمي وجميع الامور
وحاولنا نجمع الابحاث المحليه على اساس
يعني نفصل هذه لما يناسب بيئتنا وثقافتنا
في المملكه
وصلنا الى النتائج هذه
يعني مثل الاطفال اللي عندهم قله النوم
واكثر اوضة لكثير من الامراض حتى مشاكل
القلب عندهم اكثر وحتى في
المراهقين
يعني خطر الانتحار اعلى عندهم نعم
اعلى نداء الاكاديمي اللي عنده سكر يكون
السيطره عليه اصعب السمنه بشكل كبير اعلى
عندهم الاطفال اللي ما ينامون كل هذه
الامور فبناء الموجود والافضل توصلنا الى
النتائج مثلا زي ما ذكرنا المواليد مثلا
وهي منشوره بالعربي على كل حال وفيها جدول
الوليد مثلا 18 ساعه لكن الزملاء في
الاطفال مختصره وحتى ساعه قد يكون طبيعي
للمواليد بعدين تبدا طبعا المواليد
يحتاجون عده
نوبات نوم بالنهار لانه هم مقسوم مقسوم
انه ما هي ما هي فترات متساويه من النوم
تبدا تقل هذه
نقل ساعات النوم على سن ما قبل المدرسه
الابتدائيه يحتاجون غفوه واحده بالنهار
عشان كده في مثلا في الحضانه وكده يعطونهم
غفوه واحده بالنها وقد يحتاجوا مثلا الى
12 ساعه نوم بالنسبه للمواليد هل يفرق
البيئه اللي انت تحطها فيها يعني امام
يتعرض للضوء ولا يكون لا يعني
لكن بالليل يعني مهم انه يمر بدوره النوم
حق الانسان الطبيعي يعني بالليل ظلام
وبالنهار هذا
الروضه وطبعا المواليد 50% منهم يقضون
احلام حديث الولاده مو زي الانسان الكبير
لذلك يعتقد انه مهم الاحلام مهمه لنمو
الدماغ
التشابات العصبيه في الخلايا له وظيفه
مهمه ما قبل المدرسه يحتاجون غرفه واحده
11 ساعه يمكن على نهايه البدا يحتاج 10
ساعات نوم تعرضنا الى موضوع الغفوات عند
الاطفال لانه عندنا في السعوديه ياخذون
غفوات الاطفال
ومهم انهم يضبطون الساعه البيولوجيه لانهم
كثير من خاصه مع التغيرات نمط الحياه
وبعدين البالغين يعني من العشرينات مثلا
نقول بالشكل هذا وفوق العشرينات يعني بدون
حوالي سبع لتسع ساعات
تعلمنا الموضوع القيلوله قلنا القيلوله هي
في ثقافتنا والابحث عن القيلوله تختلف في
الغرب يقول لك
هم اصلا يعني انت ما تحدث على القيلوله هي
ما هي ثقافتهم فلما تكون في ثقافتهم من
اللي بيروح يقيل عندهم تعبان المريض
المريض هو اللي بيقيل لانه تعبان فلما
تقول عندهم وفيات امراض اعلى اصلا انت
العينه هذه اللي اخذتها ما يقيل عندهم الا
التعبان تعبان يعني ما اقصد يعني لكن لم
تجي في المجتمعات اللي في ثقافتهم
القيلوله سيف اليونان وجدوا ان القيلوله
مثلا القصيره تحمي من الامراض القلب
فالصين عنده ثقافه القليل ولا ايضا انها
تحمل القلب وتخفف الضغط وكذا
وجدنا انه القيلوله اذا كان لها ادابها ان
حوالي نصف ساعه حوالي بالقليل ست ساعات
بعد الاستيقاظ ونصف ساعه نصف ساعه ناقد
تكون مفيده ما في شيء ضدها لكنها شيء
اجباري لما
يسوي قيلوله
طبعا القيلوله فيها اداب لانك انت اذا
طولت ليش نص ساعه لانه بعد نص ساعه
دخلت النوم العميق ايقاظك صعب
وقد يشعر فيها الانسان حيكون جاء مجهد
ونام الظهر بعد ما تنسعل اللايك وبعد كده
جاء احد يصحيه اول ما يصحى ما يدري وينه
من اللي يكلمه وش الوقت وش اليوم ياخذ له
ثواني الين ما بعض متطور معه لحاله هذي ما
يقعد شوي ملخبط فتره فاذا دخلت واذا قام
يقعد له نص ساعه لما يصحصح لما يركز حصنه
مخه ثقيل وواسه ثقيل وصداع لانه صحوه في
المنطقه الغلط لكن اذا كانت ثلث ساعه نص
ساعه من النوم فيقول لقاط سهل وتعطي هذا
يعني فيه ايه بده يغشيكم النعاسه امنه منه
هذه اللي قبل المعركه يعني في ابحاث تقول
انه القولون القصيره تنزل ضغط الدم وتهدي
التوتر
انا كنت ابحث عنها ولا ابحث عن الاعجاز
ابحث عن الفهم فهم يعني كيف امنه منه فهمت
الان انه يعني فعلا هذه اشياء تتغير عندهم
بس الفهم عشان افهم يعني وكتبنا عنها بس
يمكن برضو في الثقافه العربيه او حتى يعني
يمكن الثقافه لما تيجي تاخذ بيت شعر من
طلب العلا سهر الليالي يعني تعطي هذا
الايحاء ان كثيرا النوم هو كسول او انسان
غير مهتم
بالعمل والحياه وغيره وان كل ما قلنا كل
ما كنت يعني واضح انك اكثر انتاجيه واكثر
عملا وانك انسان يعني يمكن هذه برضه تاثر
فكره انه النوم ممكن هو طبعا من سهر
الليالي هذه للانضباطيه يعني يعني مجازا
على الانضباط والانضباط والعمل الجاد وهو
اهم شيء للنجاح بدون شك اهم من الذكاء
واهم من كل شيء لازم يكون شخص منضبط وجاد
في عمله ملتزم فقد يكون هذا للانضباطيه
لكن السهر وقله النوم لا بدون شك انه هذا
مثبت لكن نرجع الى قضيه
يعني
من الامثال تتكونات كلهم يمكن حتى في
تسجيلات سابقه اللي مذكوره اديسون العالم
اللي اخترع الكهرباء وعنده كم اختراع وكم
اختراع كان ينام اربع ساعات وكان احد
اسباب اختراعه للكهرباء والمصباح انه
يعتقد ان النوم والليل ما ضيع الوقت يعني
اذا هذا انتجنا اكثر لكن اينشتاين ايضا
عالم اخر عبقري يقولون كان لازم ينام عشر
ساعات
يجي المختبر متضايق
وكلهم عبقريه لكن قد يكون حاجتهم لكن
الشخص الطبيعي الحرمان من النوم
مرض جدا وسيء ويقود الى كثير من الامراض
والمشاكل
طب اللي اضطر يعني هذا الانسان الطبيعي بس
اليوم احنا في هذه الحياه يكون الانسان
يعني
يعني دوام
ما يقدر يخدمها يقدر ينام بينهم طبيعي
فيكون عند الشفتات كيف يقدر يتعامل
الانسان مع هذه التغيرات الاجباريه على
الحياه طبعا الشفتات الان اصبحت يعني واقع
يعني لابد من تعايش معه الكثير من الاعمال
يعني معروف عن العمل الصحيه الامنيه
الافضل هو طبعا انه تغيير الشفت يكون مع
عقارب الساعه
وليس بعكس عقارب الساعه لانه تغيير النوم
تاخير النوم سهل وتقديم النوم صعب عشان
اسهلها لمتابعين الحين قلنا رمضان رمضان
على الابواب
واثبتناها من 25 سنه والان يوم كانت
المدارس في رمضان كان في مدارس وبعدين جت
وقفت مره ثانيه كانت طلبه يخون نومهم من
اول ليله ثلاث ساعات
ما عنده مشكله بعض المؤخره للفجر حتى لكن
تعال في شوال بدت الدراسه صح فانت ممكن
تاخر
فلازم يكون نظام التغيير مع عقارب الساعه
بعدين يتفق مع الموظفين على افضل ما
يناسبهم يعني هو الافضل انه ما تكون كل
يومين تغير لانها صعب يعني تكون قصيره يا
تكون طويله شو ما تكون يعني في النص قصير
الواحد يتاقلم بسرعه وتعطيه هذا او انها
تكون هذا اسامي
ما تخليها في النص تكون معلقه ويبدا الشخص
يحاول انه يعدل من نومه في التاخير قبل
بدايه الشفت القادم بيوم يومين يحاول يبدا
يعدل فيه ايضا اللي يشتغلون الشفتات مهم
يعطونهم اللي يسمونها غفوه الطاقه او هذا
يعني يسمحونه بيحصل على قيلوله نصف ساعه
مثلا في العمل تقول اضاعه قويه جدا اذا
كان العمل بالليل ايضا مهم انه تناول
المنبهات زي القهوه في بدايه الشيفت وليس
في نهايته ينام المهم لهم انه لما يروح
البيت يحاول يخلق بيئه الليل اذا كان شفته
بالليل وبينام بالنهار من ناحيه مو فقط
الاضاءه من ناحيه الازعاج تخلص من
الالتزامات الاجتماعيه والعائليه شوف احد
ما كان بيودي اولاد ويجيب كذا كذا صعب انه
اذا
طبعا هي صعبه في النهايه لكنها في اعمال
متعبه بهذا الشكل
الاطباء مثلا يناوبون عنده دوام اليوم
الاخر
يعني قد يحتاج انه في ساعات العمل يسمح له
اخذ يعني قيلوله قيلوله منقطع لانه اذا
كان طول الليل ممكن يعمل طول الليل
والنهار التالي او في النهار اللي يسبقه
يعطى قيلوله يسمونها قيلوله هذا وقائيه
حتى بشيء اسمه
يعني يقول لك اذا انت عندك مثلا التزام
تبغى تكون مركز فيه
وحسنك نعسان اشرب كوب قهوه ونمبعده على
طول قيلوله لانه مفعولها باخر نص ساعه
معينه مسحيه يعني او يتابعوند يعني مجموعه
يتابعونهم سنوات ويشوفون نعم كان
الامراض يعني الايوضيه الايضيه من ها
السمنه
والسمنه والسكري وامراض القلب الدمويه
كانت اعلى
متى تنام انا والله يعني احاول اكون
الساعه عشره
بالفراش وابدا يومي بدري ابدا يومي بدري
لاني
الوقت احب وقت الصباح انتج فيه وحفظه
الصباح حفظه الصباح واحب الصباح انتج كثير
في الصباح يعني انا كون عندي مسؤلات
اداريه ايضا
ومسؤلات كلينيكيه فاجد وقت الصباح جيد اني
تناولت على ايميلات اني اكتب ابحاثي وقت
اقدر اقرا بدهن صافي حتى في ناحيه الاسبوع
يعني تبع نفس النظام حتى في نهايه الاسبوع
نفس النظام يعني وعلى هذا النظام سنوات
طويله يعني سنوات كل العائله لا انت
الوحيد يعني يعني يختلفون يعني لكنها لا
يعني في كثير يحبون نوم النهار قد يكون
علي التخصص لكن انا يعني بطبعي يعني احب
الاستيقاظ بدري حتى كطفل يعني احب انام
بدري واقوم بدري يعني
عادات الاجتماعيه والعلاقات الاجتماعيه
كيف تتعامل معها والله انا يعني اروح
الاشياء اللي لازم اروحها يعني مثلا زواج
عزاء اروح يعني وحتى في الزواجات اجلس
بالكثير ساعه واستاذن اهم يعني سلمت عليهم
مجلس العشاء لان انا ما اكل عشا ثقيل
بالليل يمكن نتحدث عن الاكل بالليل تحدثنا
عنه في موضوع التوصيات الوطنيه وفي رمضان
ما اخذ عشره بالليل اخد العشاء خفيف جدا
بالليل موضوع مهم
لكن يعني ما يعني اقضي وقت كثير يعني انا
في طلعات واستراحات
يعني مثلا في الاجازات الاسبوع اللي في
غيره يعني تبقى الى بعد عشره سنه لا انا
ارجع البيت بدري اذا طلعت مثلا في مناسبه
احاول مثلا انا احب الماسات اللي في
الشتاء
لانه نصلي العشاء بدري واروح لهم بدري على
طول اجلس معهم الساعه 8:30 9:00 لاني احب
ارجع البيت رجعت متاخر ما يجيني النوم
سارجع متاخر مثلا ارجع مثلا الساعه 11 كده
خلاص اجلس صاحي
زي كذا انه ما يلتزم بنفس
الاجازات يعني حاول عدم الالتزام ياثر طيب
اللي هو احد
يلتزم في ايام الاسبوع
اغلب الناس اغلب الناس في الاجازات يا ترى
اخوي يبدا يسحب لانه المجتمع يسال يميل
للسهر يعني الانشطه الليليه ايضا اضف الى
ذلك احد اسباب القيلوله في يعني البحر
المتوسط وما جنوب ومنطقتنا الحراره في
الظهر يعني حراره الظهر كما تجبر الناس
والشعوب في المناطق هذه الاخد القيلوله في
الظهر يكون حاوي جدا في الشمال ما عندهم
الحراره هذه احد الاسباب يعني ليس فقط هي
ثقافه يعني في عادات ايضا البيئه تجبرهم
على الموضوع هذا لكن احنا يعني ايضا الناس
عنا الان الظهر يعني في بدايه الصيف ما
يصير في انشطه تماما فالناس بتطلع نشطه في
الليل هذا يساعدهم على اخذ قيلوله مثلا
بالنهار او السحر والسهر بالليل بعدين
بما ان اغلب الناس تنام متاخر يعني على
الساعه 11 12 وحده
فلما تنام تصحى لصلاه الفجر نتكلم عن اربع
ساعات خمس ساعات وترجع تنام بعدها الى
تصحى للدوام كيف تشوف هذا النمط هل السلوك
الصحي ولا
احنا في التوصيات تكلمنا على موضوع رمضان
من غير رمضان قلنا لازم اموت ساعات هذا
الصح نحن نعطي على الصحه وهذا كل واحد حسب
يعني ما يناسبه في رمضان لانه ما يمديك
تصلي التراويح وتنام سبع ثمان ساعات فقلنا
محاوله الحصول في رمضان تبعيت العصيف في
الصيف او في الباب رمضان
ست ساعات من النوم الليلي وبعدين تعويضها
بحوالي ساعتين ثلاث ساعات احس
النوم مقسوم الان الان قسمت النوم هذا
النوم مقسوم بالمناسبه ممكن نتكلم عنه
عليه دراسات هذا اكثر شيء نوم مقسوم اجري
على
[__] الفضاء
لانه رواد الفضاء عندهم ما يقدروا ينام
ثمان ساعات هم ياخذون شفتات اربعه كذا
فينام اربع ساعات وبعدين اربع ساعات وكذا
فيقسمونهم يصير اربع اشياء اربع ساعات
النوم المقسوم طبعا
احنا
المعلومات اللي عندنا واللي درسنا ايضا في
في الصيف وفي النوم مع نفس العينه درسناهم
وقسنا النوم وقسنا مراحل النوم وتكوين
النوم في التخطيط
او بناء النوم الهيكلي
والتركيز والعده الفعل وكل امور هذه ما
تتنفذ لكن على المدى القصير الطويل ما
ادري
فنعم اللي ما يقدر ينام زي كذا يحتاج انه
يعوض بدون شك يحتاج يعوض بالنهار وهذا ما
عاد يصير قيلوله مقسوم
على المدى الطويل هل له نفس التاثير هو
نفس التاثير اللي هو متواصل بالليل ما
ندري لكن لنعلمه انه اللي ما بالاسبوع
ويجي يحاول يعوض بالويكند في الابحاث
الموجوده حاليا تقول لها انه ما يكفي ما
يكفي قد يكون اكثر عرضه مثلا والمشاكل
الاخرى
بما ان رمضان على الابواب وفتحت الموضوع
ودي اعرف كيف الشكل المثالي في رمضان
يتغير كل شيء يعني عندنا
تغير نمط الاكل
تغيير وقت النوم
يعني في ناس يعني فتتسحر وتنام بعدها
والسحور يكون ثقيل لان كنت وراك ينطي
كيف الشكل اللي يصير رمضان علينا وكيف
ممكن نتعامل مع الاكل طبعا ممكن في
الدائره لو سمحتي بس بقول انه احنا لما
نتكلم على رمضان اتكلم من
15 سنه من العمل على هذا الموضوع من البحث
العلمي يعني ما اتكلم انا من توصيات منظم
ولا يعني هذا حكيم يعني ماني حكي علمي
احنا اكثر ناس في العالم اشتغلنا على
رمضان والنوم في العالم
ثاني جامعه في العالم على الصحه ولا رمضان
اغلب ابحاثنا على رمضان فهم يعني في ناس
يشتغلوا على السكري كثير فعلى السكري انا
عندي شغل بس قليله اشتغل على السكري وعلى
الكبد بس
وجدنا في رمضان وتكلم لما بدانا عام 99
وجدنا يعني 1419
وجدنا انه الناس تاخروا نومها من اول ليله
في رمضان ثلاث ساعات ايام كانت النشاط
الليلي اقل الناس تقفل بالليل وكان في
طالب وكان في مدارس ذاك الوقت يا اخي
ونومهم ويدخرون استيقاظهم وبعدين ينامون
قبل نفس الساعات اليوم لكن
نبدا الفكره هذه بالمناسبه
كثير من الناس في العوف يقول لك انه والله
انا رمضان نعسان حتى نشوف
يعني
للاساتذه اتمنى يعمل خريج او الخنيفر ولا
بعضهم بعضهم الشباب كلهم اللي يسوون كلهم
يعلقون على هذا انا مجمع عندي يعني
بشكل كبير جدا
هل الصيام رمضان يزيد النعاس
ونشرنا يمكن فوق الاربعين بحث في هذا
المجال يعني وعنا فكره ايضا عمل كتاب لهذا
الموضوع كتاب علمي
فاولا لو تكلمنا على النماذج الحيوانيه
على اساس نفهم بعدين
يصوم لكن يسمونه او حصل السعرات الحراريه
لما تقل السعرات الحراريه اللي شبيه
بالصوم لساعات معينه يزيد نشاطه
وهذا وجدناه لما وجدنا المتطوعين في
المختبر
اسلامي في رمضان وفي خارج رمضان
لماذا خارج رمضان لانه خارج في رمضان في
نمط حياه يتغير يؤثر عليهما اتكلم عنه
الان لكن خارج الموضوع ما في نمط الحياه
هذه متعوده ويقوم الصبح يكون في العمل
الساعه سبعه ونص فخليه يجي سبعه ونص وينام
بالليل نفس الوقت وجدنا انه ما اثر على
التركيز قسناهم التركيز حتى العصر يعني
التنفيذ وقدت الفعل والاشياء هذا موجود في
اختلاف بينهم ولا وجدنا اختلاف كثير في
ايقاع الهرمونات
اللقاء الهرمونات الميلاتونين جميعها
قسناها متغيرات الالتهابات الخلويه
المضادات الاكسده ما وجدنا فيها اختلاف
بالعكس يبحث انه افضل مع الصيام طيب الان
ايش اللي يحدث في رمضان في رمضان في تغير
في نمط الحياه اولا تعود للتكلم
تاخير النوم تاخير النوم من اول ليله في
بعض الابحاث يرتبط بالاكتئاب
تاخير النوم المفاجئ
بالاكتئاب قد يزيد الاكتئاب داخل النوم
المفاجئ ايضا قد يلخبط كثير من الامور في
الجسم
الانشطه الليليه تزداد
يساعد في قلب الساعه البيولوجيه
في رمضان عندنا انا اقول هذا
يعني عندنا في بعض هذا
وفيه مفتوح صح ولا لا
وش مشكله الاكل بصفه عامه يعني السعرات
مهمه السعرات مشكله الاكل هي البوفيه
المفتوح
لانه في نقطه قد تغيب عن البعض كل ما زادت
غاز الانسولين كل ما زادت السمنه كنا زادت
مقاومه الجسم الانسولين وزاره التجمع
الكبد والمشاكل الاخرى لذلك جيد انه
الانسولين يفرز وبعدين يجلس فترات ما في
انسولين عشان المستقبلات تتنشط وتتحقق
وكذا اذا الاكل مفتوح طول اليوم
يه سهل تسيطر عليها نقدر نسيطر عليها وعنا
ابحاث حتى على حيوانيه الان بس لكن بعد في
بعض نتائج يعني في النماذج الحيوانيه
مثلا اغلب النماذج تكون على فئران التجارب
يعني فران التجارب هي فتره النشاط عندها
بالليل
والخمول بالاكتيف بعكس انسان انسان
كانهاري وهذا ايضا في القران كثيرا من
الادله
كانها كائن اذا يحطون غذاء يسمونه يعني
بوفيه مفتوح وقت النشاط
اكلوه بالنهار وقتل هذا يزيد وزنه يزيد
وزن هذا لما ناكل طول الليل طول الليل طول
النفق التاثير للصيام الصحي نفقد تاثير
الاسلام الصحي لانه انت هذا مو وقت اكل
لذلك في التوصيات الوطنيه وضعنا
الرئيسيتين
وجبه تكون مثلا الافطار بعض الناس وتروح
تصلي بعضهم ياكل على الافطار وبعدين يصلي
المهم تكون وجبه مثلا تامر وقهوه ومويه
وكده يصلي بعدين يجي ياكل وجبه مهم ياكل
وجبه لانه ياكل وجبه وبعدين ممكن ياخذ
سناك وجبه خفيفه وبعدين الوجبه السحور هي
الوجبه الثانيه المفروض تكون وجبه اذا طبق
هذا النظام حتى في المختبر كل القياسات
تتحسن كل الامور عندهم حاجه الان تحسنات
في الصيام لكن اذا انت بوفيه طول الليل
تفقد تاثير الصيام الصحي ويعرضك لزياده
الوزن ومشاكل ومضاعفات والسكري والاشياء
هذه لانه انت بتاكل في وقت ما مناسب للاكل
ومهم انه بعد الاكل انه بعد السحور هذا
الصح هذا الصح صحيا طبيا الواحد ما ينام
لانه النوم بعده وجبه ثقيله سيئه وفي
الغرب دراسات كثيره على على وجبه العشاء
يكون العشاء وينام مو جيد يعني النوم يكون
اسوا قد يرفع ضغط الدم الناس عندهم سكري
يعمل مشاكل كثيره لهم فما هو وقت جيد
للنوم بعد الهدم كمل كمفترض الفتره ما بين
الاكل الوجبه الثقيله احنا نقول على الاقل
اربع ساعات وقت العشاء عليها ابحاث وجبه
العشاء ايضا لها عليها دراسات
يعني خفيف قد يساعد في النوم وجبه خفيفه
لكن
القليل ثلاث اربع ساعات قبل النوم فهذا هو
اللي ينقض التاثيرات الصحيه للنوم لكن في
احنا مجموعه بحثيه من عده دول يعني كونسور
مجموعه في عندنا كثير من الابحاث ننشرها
تاثيرات الصحيه للنوم مثلا
متلازمه الايض عن انزيمات الكبد التي قد
تعكس التدخل وتشمع الكبد عن كثير من
الامور الصيام في رمضان
بالرغم من انه اغلب الابحاث عملت بدون
تحكم في العوامل الاخرى اللي في نمط
الحياه
المجمل الصيام كان مفيد على اغلب الامور
هذه نقص الوزن كثير من الاشياء لكن يفقدها
الشخص بعد
شوال بعد شوال يفقدها تماما
كثير من الابحاث اللي انا اشتغلت عليها في
مختبرنا في الجامعه كنا نسيطر على
المحادثه داخل المختبر فيكون العينات
قليله ثمانيه 12 شخص ما اقدر اجيب
اسيطر على الامور هذه على اساس ما تختلف
في معلومه يعني وجدناها قد تكون يعني شيقه
انه
درسنا مره مره بقياس بالسؤال وموجه بقياس
النوم في شكل موضوعي
وجدنا انه حتى غير المسلمين في السعوديه
يقلب لهم
مع انه دمهم ما يتاخر
لو هم ما يتاخر عاده
فيما يتاخر ما يصوم بس المجتمع كله يسهل
كنمط الحياه في لودور اساسي في قلبه
الساعه هذه البيولوجيه لكن الصيام بحد
ذاته ما ياثر عليها يعني يعملها وعملنا
دراسه مره على جبنه شباب الصغار عندهم ان
كان عندهم اجازه كانت ايامها شعبان اجازه
ما هو هذا وكانوا متعودين يقومون المغرب
يعني وجباتهم الرئيسيه مع تغير وجبه
الرئيسيه تحدد الساعه البيولوجيه فدرسناهم
في شعبان جبنا نفس الشباب
نمط الحياه وهذا النمط ما هو الصحي يعني
غير صحي وهذا يعني مثبت احنا كتبنا مقال
علمي
عام 2020
بتاخير وقت المدرسه والعمل نعمه او نقمه
بالانجليزي نعمه او نقمه
واللي حرك هذا الموضوع انه الجمعيات
العلميه المهتمه بموضوع النوم
في ذاك العام اصدروا كلهم يعني بيان وعلى
الاصل الاكاديميه الامريكيه لطب النوم
تقول انه قديسه هذا اللي هو توفير الساعه
نهار ضوء النهار اللي تؤخر في الغلب على
اساس يكسبون ساعه في البرد وكذا على اساس
هذا ينصحون بضدها
في الابحاث انه 6% من الحوادث المميته
زياده الحوادث
وامراض القلب والجلطات تزيد في الفتره هذه
فاحنا قلنا الان اخذنا القياس نفسه وهذا
العلماء محايدين يعني غير مسلمين
قلنا الان احنا في رمضان ناخذ
يعني ثلاث ساعات او الدوام هون هنا اخر
وساعه وفترتها اطول منها احنا شهر واحد
وفضلتهم اطول هم يغيرونها مرتين بالسنه
وبعدين بعد شهر نقلبهم مره ثانيه
تقول انه موضوع هذا قد يكون يحتاج له يعني
نظل وبحث واعاده ناظر لانه اذا اخذنا
الابحاث هذه ما في سبب يخليني اقول حنا
مختلفين عن العالم ذولا
اخذناها بس يعني نسخ ولصق هنا فهل هذا صحي
ولا لا السؤال هذا فقط كما قال العلمي
بالانجليزي يعني المجله علميه هذا
بسير المواضيع كباحثه واكاديمي
ما يتغير يعني اقول انه هذا صحي قد يحتاجه
دراسه يعني انا دائما في الامور هذه انا
اقول انه في امور تنظيميه وامنيه واداريه
واقتصاديه انا غير ملم فيها انا انا باحث
يعني عالم ينظر للامور بناحيه علميه فقط
ما ينظر الامور التنظيميه هذه اشخاص اعلم
مني وافهم مني لكن انا اقول هذا فيها شيء
يعني عادل منظمين بعدين يجدون لها شيء
يعني مش الحل يبقى كما هو انا ارى انه
الافضل يعني
الامور الاخرى انه يبقى الدوام كما هو
ويطلع الناس من الدوام بدري اطلع بدري
وياخد له قيلوله يعوض الوقت اللي مثلا ما
نام بالليل جيد يعوض الوقت هذا ودوام يكون
بدري
او حتى يقدم ويطلع مثلا الساعه 12 من
الدوام بدل ما يطلع الساعه ثلاثه مثلا من
الدوام يطلع الساعه 12:00 عنده وقت يرتاح
وحتى ينهي بعدين الشادبون الشيء هذا اعمال
اخرى
علمي اكاديمي
طبية أنا حتى يعني يمكن تاخير الدوام
يساعد في في نمط السهر بل انك انت تدري بس
بدون شك بدون شك يساعده وايضا يعني غير
صحي تاكل وجبه ثقيله وتنام ما هو
يعني غير صحي هذا ابدا متى تنام في رمضان
والله شوف في بدايه الشهر احاول احافظ على
نفس النظام نفس نظام نومي بس مع نهايه
الشهر يبدا يتاخر نحصل على نوم بالليل
يبدا يتاخر يعني مع الصلاه مع كذا مع كذا
يبدا يتاخر بس احاول اني مهما كان حتى
نهايه الشهر اخذ لي بعض الساعات النوم
بالليل يعني على الاقل اربع ساعات
لكن طبعا في العشر الاواخر يعني حاله خاصه
حاله خاصه يعني العشره واخر حاله خاصه
الايام اللي ما فيها عمل حاله خاصه هي
اجازه لكن ايام العمل يعني كثير من الناس
يعاني يعاني في العمل لانه اضطراب الساعه
البيولوجيه يعني الشباب
رمضان يعجبهم الشباب الصغار يحب ياخلوهم
بس الكبار واحد تعدل 45 50 يعانون ترى في
الدوام هذا ما يناسبهم طيب الحين يجي بعد
رمضان
وتيجي ازمه شوال
فالعاده ان الكل يبدا يرتبك يومه ويختلف
عكس عقارب ساعه فكيف تشكل المثالي للتعامل
مع ضبط النوم بعد رمضان وطبعا في شواء
يعني لو شبهناها يعني اللي يسافرون كثير
مسابات بعيده يعرفون هالشي يعني انت بتروح
امريكا الان تتاقلم مع النظام بسرعه لكن
لو يكون مبتعس ويجي من امريكا يرجع
السعوديه ياخذ وقت لما يتاقلم فدخول رمضان
زي السفر نومك شوال زي سافر من الغرب تقدم
نومك اصعب الان
يعني ما في حل سحري وعصا سحريه كل ما كان
الواحد اصلا بالسن الاطفال يتاقلمون
المراهقين يجدون صعوبه لانهم جسمهم النظام
وتقول انا نقدم ما يستطيع لكن المفروض
الاستعداد يبدا له قبل يعني ما تنتهي
الاجازه باسبوع اجازه اسبوعين اجازه بعد
العيد فالاسبوع الاخير هذا يبدا التاقلم
معه ما يمكن تجي ليله الدوام او المدارس
والان بعدل النوم اغلبهم يروحوا مواصلين
فلا بد من هذا والعمل الاساسي اللي هو
الضوء نرجع لموضوع الضوء يعني الاطفال
مثلا يحاولوا يبدون يقدموا لهم في
استيقاظهم شوي شوي يطلعونهم نشاط خارجي
بره يتعرضون لاشياء مجلسهم بس بالبيت في
المساء يبعدون على الالعاب الصبح يلعبوا
فيها ما في مشكله قللوا منها في المساجل
المنبهات الصباح نعسان خذ منبهات ابدا
التعود والتاقلم
لانه هو تقريبا يعني في العرف الطبي
الانسان يستطيع تعديل
التايم زون ساعه باليوم يعني اذا انتقلت
مثلا الى اختلاف ثمان ساعات قد تحتاج
ثمانيه ايام عشان تعدل
في ناس ما عندهم مشكله يعدل بسرعه من اول
يوم يضبط معهم لكن الناس عندهم صعوبه عاده
ساعه باليوم تحط بالك انه ساعه باليوم
اخذت ساعه من رمضان يمكن يعني كل يوم تعدل
يلا تعدل ساعه قد يكون بالكثير ساعتين فما
تتوقع انك تعدل الليله وحده اغلب الناس ما
يستطيع فبنجي الحين ودي اعرف الاضطرابات
انه مش اكثر اضطرابات انهم الشيوعين عندنا
طبعا اضطرابات النوم هي فيها تصنيف عالمي
وتخص طب النوم يعني ظهري يمكن بدايه
الثمانينات بشكل اول كانوا حديث حديث او
كانوا يهتمون بالنوم من ناحيه العلميه
بحثيه بس كالطب كطب كطباء يعني في
الثمانينات ودخل عليه اطب الصدر وشكل اكبر
لانه اكبر مشكله هي انقطعت انفسنا النوم
فدخل في امريكا الشمالي بشكل اكبر
والنفسيه اطب الاعصاب وطب النفسيه هم
الاكثر بالصدر وهم اللي يعني مهيمنين على
الموضوع اول تصنيف عالم
تصنيف عام 2005 عام 2014 تصنيف عن يمكن
يضم حوالي 100 اضطراب كل اضطراب له شروط
التشخيصيه تحت تحت سبع مجموعات كبيره يعني
طلبات النوم الارق الطلبات التنفس اثناء
النوم
فقط النعاس وزاده النعاس الارتباط بالجهاز
العصبي زي مثلا في النوم القهري الطلبات
الساعه البيولوجيه البراس النوم
زي الكوابيس واحد يسوي حلمه
الحركات التي تحدث خلال النوم الحركات
وتشنج لي قد يكون شيجون الحالات هذه بعد
الطلبات النوم الاخرى اللي ما حصلولها شيء
للانين اثناء النوم اشياء مثل هذه الناس
فهذه الاضطرابات كل الاضطرابات حقه موجوده
في المملكه والشايعين في الدراسات طبعا
عندنا يعني دراسات مستوى الغرب ولكن عندما
تزيد الان والمهتمين بالبحث العلمي في
المملكه الان في ازدياد الكثير من الشباب
يعني
الشعب يعني اللي عنده اهتمام بهالموضوع
يعني لو اخذنا مثلا قطاع الطمس اثناء
النوم يعني اكبر المشاكل احنا زي الغابه
تقريبا في الشيوع يعني يعني حوالي مثلا
يمكن عشره بالمئه في متوسطه العمر من
الرجال من السيدات
في السيدات قد يكون اعلى من الغرب لانه
السمنه في السيدات عندهم متوسط
[موسيقى]
لو خدمه اضطرابات وخدمه النوم القهري لانه
النوم القهري هو مرض نادر
ونوم القهري هذا مرضي مناعي مثله مثل
السكري النوع الاول اجسام مضاده تهاجم
مركز في المخ يسمى مركز تحت
خلايا تفرز ناقل عصبي يسبب اليقظه
زي ما تهاجم الاجسام المضاده خلايا
البيتاس في البنكرياس وتسبب السكر من
الاطفال عاده نصيب المراهقين
في الكبار ايضا مرض مناعي ما هو السبب الى
الان يعني
قد يكون عده اسباب بيئيه او يعني في
البيئه او شيء
او شبه القبيل
من النوم لا يمكن مقاومتها لا يمكن
مقاومتها لو جالس الان في لقاء بينام
الشيء الاخر شلل اليقظه عندهم النسبه منهم
حوالي 60% وانا اليقظه اذا اي موقف عاطل
بدايه الضحك ينشل قد ينشل الكامل يعني
تطيح راس ويطيح الشكل العينين تنزل الجفون
كلام يصير بطيء او قد يسقط سقوط كامل على
الارض
ويكون واعي وعي تام لكنه مشلول
والجاثوم
طبعا حميد يصحى من النوم هو مشلول
يصير عندهم شكل كبير هذا ايضا تقطع في
النوم بالليل نسبه كبيره منهم زياده في
الوزن يزيد وزنه
في السابق وهذا ايضا عندنا يعني فيها
مباحث كثيره في هذا الموضوع ليش شلل
اليقظه والجاسوم لانه هذا الناقل العصبي
الاوكسين يعمل استقلال للنوم
يخلي النقل بين اليقظه
والنوم مستقره ويهيج نراقب اخرى السبب
اليقظه ويخلي الدخول لانتقال من الاحلام
مراحل اخرى او من الاحلام لليقظه سلس
في الاحلام الجسم ينشل
احساس واحد ما يقوم مسوي حلمي في اضطرابات
بالاحلام السلوكي الواحد يقوم يسوي الحلم
هذا غير مشي اثناء النوم واحد يكون قد
يكون في اكشن في احلامه لكنه ما يتحرك
مشلول جنبه بس شوف العين لما تحركت
من النوم سبحان الله تختفي الاليه هذه
هم يصحى من النوم تبقى الاليه
اضطراب عاطفي لانه المنطقه المسؤوله عن
الناقل العصبي ايضا عن الاكل ومسؤول عن
العواطف فيها خلطه اختفى هذا فتدخل
الاحلام على اليقظه يدخل من الاحلام من
تاثيرها الشلل شلل اليقظه ما يدخل النوم
كامل يدخل بس الشلل اي تفاعل العاطفي
احيانا الغضب الموقف الضحك
يدخل شلل يسببهم احراج كبير احيانا بعض
الطلبه يعني يعني اغلبهم يتعاطف زملائه
لكن بعضهم بيحاولوا زملاء ويضحكون على
اساس هذا لكن اغلب الطلبه حقيقتين يعني في
مجتمع يعني طيب يعني يتعرفون مع زملائهم
لكن قد تصل بعضهم يحرج يقول لك انا اضحك
مع زملائي الاطفال
ينعزل وينطوي ينطوي بعدين هذا هو مرض
النوم النوم القهري هذا عندنا اتوقع حوالي
اربعين
في كل مئه الف يعني قلنا مثلا السعودي
مثلا 30 خبزاتين مليون على الاف بضع
الالاف
لها علاج نيجي موضوع العلاج عنا مشكله في
العلاج مشكله العلاج انه طبعا في لها
ادويه مقربه من زمان يعني مشكله الادويه
انها ماتتوفر بشكل سهل في المملكه لانها
ما عندها تصنيف من هي الدواء والغذاء
الهيئه العامه الدواء والغذاء لانه هذه
تسمى ادويه يتيمه يتيمه في ادويه يتيمه
يعني مستخدمينها قليلين في اغلب الدول
يصير فيها تسهيلات في الدخول وفي هذا ما
يدخل عندهم رسوم انا ما اعرف شو النظام
يعني انا ما احط فيه لكنه انا مثلا
الاسئله يقولون
الاجراءات صعبه شوي ما نقدر نسجل الدواء
يصير نطلبه طلب شراء مباشر
ويتعاونوا معنا
وكل الدول هذه يستخدم
فما تتوفر مثلا في القطاع الخاص صعب في
القطاع الخاص وفي القطاع الحكومي تتوفى
وتنقطع احيانا واذا انقطعت عن المرضى
تنتكس حالتهم تنتكس تماما
هو طالب بالجامعه في بدايه حياته المهنيه
تنتكس حياته يعني نوم وكذا
بشكل طبيعي
عندنا دراسه طوليه تابعنا للمرضى عشر
سنوات بعض الاعراض تختفي هذا يتحسن الوقت
الجاثوم ووزنهم يستقر ايضا في البدايه
يزيد بعدين يستقر يسوون عندهم سمنه تقطع
النوم بالليل كذا لكن زياده النعاس تبقى
يحتاجون المنبه طبعا ادويه نوعين في اشياء
سلوكيه وفي ادويه للتنبيه ادويه طبيه
وادويه للشلل اليقظه هذا محرج جدا
مزعج تخيل يعني هذا تطيح
وانت واعي لحولك قد استمر ثواني الى دقائق
طيب فهذا بالنسبه للنوم
احنا قلنا يعني في اضطرابات اخرى يعني
المركزي الشخير يعتبر
طبيعي انه الانسان يشخر احيانا في نومه
ولا هذا مرض
الشخير هو عرض لكن مو طبيعي مو كل واحد
وكان مجهد يشخر وعنده انفلونزا او لكن اذا
ليليا مو طبيعي معناه في ضيق التنفس
وجدنا الشخير حوالي يعني خمسين بالمئه من
متوسط العمر الرجال يقول عندي شخير ومتوسط
العمر النساء اربعين بالمئه طبعا اللي
يشخر احيانا كثير منهم ما يدري انه ما حد
قال له هذه النسبه هي
تقلل يعني قد تكون اعلى فالشخير شائع جدا
الشخيل يعني طبعا هو مزعج اولا الشريك
وجدت انا عن كثير من الازواج منفصله
[موسيقى]
وفي الغالب وجدت
ازواج فصلوا
الى الطلاق الحمد لله
لكن وجدتم ينفصوم هذا الشيء يعني يعني صعب
انك يعني زوجين يعني فقط يعني موضوع يمكن
علاجه متى الشيخ يكون مغلق مغلق اذا كان
لاحظوا اذا كان شخص يعاني من الاختناق
يصحى مختنق من النوم او الزوج تلاحظ انه
يقطع النفس
تقطع النفس وانت نايم اذا كان عنده ضغط دم
شنو نقطع النفس يعني يكون يشغل وبعدين
يقطع ثواني حناخذ شخره كبيره يبدا مره
ثانيه
اذا كان عنده ضغط دم ضغط ضغط دم يصعب
السيطره عليه لانه واحد اسباب صعوبه
السيطره على ضغط الدم بالادويه اذا كان
عندهم امراض بالقلب عنده سكري كان عنده
قدر الله جلطه في القلب او في الدماغ لابد
من النظر في الموضوع عنده تكرار في التبول
يعني يستيقظ التبول اللي عنده زياده
بالنعاس او ضعف التركيز بالنهار هذه كلها
معنى انه قد يكون في ليس فقط وانما ايضا
انقطاع في التنفس
فيحتاج انه يزور طبيب مختص لعمل تخطيط
للنوم لانه انقطاع التنفس اثناء النوم
كمرض يزيد خطر الاصابه بعده امراض اخرى
مثبت الان وضمن ضمن اسباب ضغط الدم
الكليه الامريكيه للقلب في هذا العام في
سبعه عوامل لصحه القلب
يعني منها اشياء معروفه لو تذكرتها الان
مثلا التدخين ضغط الدم يعني تجنب
النيكوتين ضغط الدم السكري
الكوليسترول
مش القلب
السنه هذه مده النوم اضفوها مده النوم
لازم مده النوم لصحه القلب اضافتها الكليه
الامريكيه لطب النوم السنه هذه فهو يزيد
خطا الى قدر الله ضغط الدم صلوا الشرايل
القلب والدماغ
ايضا الدراسات الحديثه ربطت بينها وبين
الخرف زياده الحرف وانتباسات الحديثه ايضا
تربط بين انقطاع التنفس وزاد خطر الاصابه
ببعض الاورام الخبيثه
فهناك مؤشرات انه يعني هذا تزيد من خطر
الامور هذه فاذا يعني يحتاج انه تعالج
بسيادات تقلل الابحات الحديثه تقلل من
كثير من المضاعفات هذه تقلب مشيئه الله
لما نقول الجاثوم وشو الجاثوم علميا وش
اللي يحصل
النوم يكون الشخص مرحله الاحلام
الاحلام يكون مشلول هذا حتى لما نقيس
العضلات تكون مشلوله ما عدا الحجاب الحاجز
والعينين العين ينتهز والحجاب الحاجز طبعا
فتحات الجسم تكون مقفله
اول ما يصحى الشخص من الحلم ينتهي الشلل
هذا
الجاثوم يستمر الشلل
فيحس الشخص انه ما يستطيع الحركه ولانه
كان في حلم قد يتهيا له بعض الامور انه
احد جاسم على صدمه
حتى الخواجات في رسومات ويحطون جني على
هذا الموقع انا انا عندي في الموضوع جزء
انجليزي فكاتب عن الكثير من الاضطرابات
بالانجليزي
حذفت ايميله او انه ضاع مني يوصف لي نفس
القضيه اللي توصف عندنا انه جني دخل جلس
على صدوره وكذا وانه بدا يتلو بعض الاشياء
من الانجيل وكذا انها انه بعدين راح الجني
هذا انا عن نفسي في الثقافه حتى في
رسوماتهم جني كذا يخنق واحد يعني فجات
منها كلمه الجاثوم يبدو لي يعني هذا اساس
الكلمه لكن كل اللي يحصل انك كنت
اقول بعض الناس يزعل مني وبعض ويزعل مني
انا كطبيب وكباحث اكاديمي وباحث تطبيقي ان
هذا تفسير الى الامر وهذا تفسير العلمي
وهذا المعروف حتى كتب عنه مثلا لما كتبنا
كتب عنه بعض العلماء المسلمين السابقين
ومعروف انه مثلا لو انت جهدت نفسك قبل
النوم قد يزيد لو اكلت وجبه يزيد هذا
هذا تفسيرنا العلمي
والله انا ما اقيس الجن قد يكون في جن هذا
ما ادري بس هذا هذا اللي عندي واعرف انه
اذا قلنا للاحلام تختفي يعني مثلا اللي
عندهم نوم القهوي نعطيهم ادويه تقلل من
الشلل اليقظه تقل مرحله الاحلام
نقلل من الاعراض هذه وهل الانسان عادي انه
ما يحلم
لا كل الناس تحلم لكن الناس ما تتذكر
احلامهم واللي ما تذكر الاحلام او لما
يتذكر الاحلام اللي عنده اهتمام بالاحلام
ففي ناس عندهم اهتمام بالاحلام اكبر مثلا
السيدات عندهم اهتمام بالاحلام اكثر
ايضا منطقتنا يهتمون بالاحلام اكثر منطقه
يعني العربيه والاسلاميه يهتمون بالاحلام
وتاويل الاحلام وتفسيرها اكثر
فقد تكون الاحلام اكثر حتى في بحث اجري في
مصر وبحث اجري في الامارات عندي اهتمام
بموضوع في عندي كتابات عن تفسير الاحلام
فسروا الاحلام ابن سيرين وابن خلوه من
قدامه في هذا الموضوع
يعني حتى المتعلمين يهتمون بموضوع الاحلام
والتفسير الاحلام اقل تعليما لا حتى
المتعلمين عندهم اهتمام في في هذا الموضوع
فاللي عنده اهتمام اكثر اللي نومه متقطع
في الحلم لسبب مختلف يعني قد يكون قطاع
تنفس ولا كذا يتذكر الحلم اكثر وقد يكون
عنده قوابيس لانه نحن وجدنا في الابحاث
انه عندهم تقاطع تنفس في الاحلام فقط
قد يختفي
ايضا اللي يوقظ من الحلم قد يذكر الحلمه
واللي يصحى من مرحله ما يحلم قد ما يتذكر
انه اذا عدى الحلم هو ما ما قام قد ما
يتذكر الحلم يعني ايضا زي ما تذكرنا في
بدايه الحلقه
الحلم ايضا قد يكون جينات معينه في ناس
جيناتهم بشكل اكبر في ناس ما تهتم
بالاحلام ما تعطيها وزن فما تتذكر الاحلام
عاده لكن هي مرحله اساسيه وكل انسان نوم
ونوم صحي يمر بالمرحله هذه طيب هلا عرفنا
من وين تيجي الاحلام مش طبيعتها يعني
محتوى الاحلام
وفي النهايه الامر يعني يعكس الواقع اللي
نعيشه
الواقع لنعيشه يعني شيء مر علينا وكان في
ذهننا سواء القينا له بال او لم نلقي له
بال وقد يظهر في الحلم عندنا فلو واحد حلل
الحلم يجد انه شيء مر عليه اغلب الاحيان
يكون شيء يعني يتعرض له بشكل مختلف بشكل
مختلف طبعا محتوى الاحلام يختلف على حسب
الاشخاص
مثل الاطفال قد يغلب عليه الحيوانات
والالوان والاشياء السيدات
الحوار اللفظي يعني
الرجال قد يكون اكشن احيان اختلاف حده قد
يكون احيانا يعني حتى يعني نزاعه وهذا في
مجال لانه اللي عندهم مثلا اضطراب الاحلام
السلوكي بعضهم كثير منه يضرب في الحلم
واحنا نصوره بزوجته نتكلم
طبعا مو موجود
الانسان الكفيف مثلا
اذا كان سال كفيف
وهو مثلا بعد سن مثلا ست سنوات عشر سنوات
كذا قد يتذكر صور فيحلم فيها اذا هو كفيف
قبل السن هذا يغلب عليه الاحاسيس الاخرى
حاسس مثلا الحديث
لكن الجميع يحلم
هذا اضطراب
الباحث في الشلل بعكس الجاثوم
يحدث في الشلل هذا ما يحدث في الشلل
فيقوم الشخص
ويسوي الحلم
طبعا قد تكون حركه عنيفه وقد تكون حركه
داخل السله الخفيفه
هذا اضطراب عاده بعكس الجاثوم اذا كان
معزول لوحده بجوز هذا عاده ما يكون حميد
اغلب الحالات تكون مصحوبه بامراض عصبيه
تنكسيه
مثل مرض الشلل وعاش
او غيره من الامراض العصبيه التنفسيه وقد
يسبق ظهور الامارات
او اكثر وقد يكون معزول يعني هو بس ظهر
وماله شيء اخر يعني
لما يظهر في الشباب
في الشباب في نقطه اساسيه يحتاج نشوفها
كثير من الادويه النفسيه مضادات الاكتئاب
او
الموديل هذه هذه قد تهيج ظهورها والمرضى
مصابين بالنوم القهري نتحدثنا عنه عندهم
هذا الاضطراب فهو اضطراب اذا كان موجود هو
يخلف على المشي اثناء النوم المشي اثناء
النوم يحدث في النوم العميق
والتراب حميد يحدث الاطفال وهو اضطراب
حميد يختفي وماله اثار طويله الامد على
الانسان يعني لا نفسيا ولا عضويا ولا
ستطلب علاج يعني عاده ننبه على بعض ونتاكد
انه ما في شيء اخر يعني اذا كان مثلا طفل
عاده النوم العميق يكون في الطفل الاول من
النوم فيكون عاده في الثلث الاول من النوم
يقوم يمشي وتكامل واذا كان مجهد يمشي لك
الليله
المشي اثناء النوم صعب يقابل الطفل من
لانه عم صعب ايقاضه والصباح ما يتذكر
ويكون الصباح طبيعي ما كانه قام ولا شيء
ولا حاجه يعني اذا كان في العائله ان هذا
فيه عامل وراثي قوي اذا كان في العائله بس
ننبهم على بعض الامور يعني ما يكون مرتفع
ما يكون في اشياء حاده في الغرفه باب
الغرفه مثلا مقفول يحطوله مفتاح الاقام
يعرف وين يطلع وكذا ما يطلع لو كان في
شباك يفتح يكون عليه حديد قبل خارجي
نفسه طبعا لكنه كاضطراب في الطفل على
المدى الطويل حمل
ونتاكد انه قد يهيج هذا الاضطراب اشياء
اخرى مثلا الشقيق
لو وجدنا احتمال شخيل او اختناق او انقطعت
لانهم لازم يعالج انه يساعد من هذه
الاضطرابات خطر النوم لازم تعالج لكن اذا
وجدنا كل الامور طيبه ما في داعي الاضطراب
الاحلام مختلف سهل يقاضي المريض وحتى يحدث
اكثر في الاخير من النوم
ايقاظ المريض سهل واذا اي خط الميته تذكره
انه كان في حلو بالضبط لو كنت في حلم كذا
كذا طيب واللي يتكلم وهو نايم الكلام
اثناء النوم هذا اضطراب مختلف هذا قد يعني
يكون اضطراب منعزل يعني وقد يحدث في اي
مرحله مراحل النوم ويكون في كثير من
الاحيان حميد مو صعب علاجه وقد يصاحب
اضطرابات اثناء النوم
بالاحلام السلوكي قد يصاحبها هذا فاذا
عالجنا المشكله هذه
يختفي وقد يكون ماله سبب يعني مرحله
طيب الان يعني مع هذا كله مع هذه
الاضطرابات ولا المشاكل التي تحصل مثلا
انه انا واحد مثلا هنا في السعوديه وفي اي
مكان عاده ان اتجه الى من علشان يعالجني
طبيب
يعني تنفس وصدر ريح وكذا ولا طبيب ايش
بالضبط هو طبعا الحمد لله انا في المملكه
طب النوم اصبح طب مصنف في الهيئه خاصه
طبيعي نعم
فالسعوديه هي ثالث دوله في العالم تنشر
تصنيف لطب النوم بعد امريكا والمانيا
واشارت لهذا الجمع الامريكيه للصدر
والجمعه الاوروبيه للتنفس
السعوديه وكذا وكذا
التصنيف
ظهروا في عام 2011 يعني في مجله على اساس
يطلع العالم في
2012 تقريبا الطبيب الممارس يصنف من
الهيئه هذا الطبيب طب
النوم يعني السعوديه رائده في التخصص
للموضوع هذا ما تنطب النوم سنه 2018 احنا
سبقنا كثير من دولتك سبقنا كل دول اسيويه
ما فيها اليابان كوريا الصين الهند وانا
يعني علاقه علميه كثير مع الباحثين في
اسيا لانه من مؤسسي الجمعيه لاسوي الطب
النوم وعندنا الجماعات كثيره وتواصل وكذا
فكنت دائما تكلمهم عن التصنيف وعن كذا وعن
الاشياء الاطباء والفنيين وكانوا يعني هم
معجبين انه السعوديه هم قاعدين يصنفون الى
الان
في عام 2020
شكلت الجميع الاسيويه لجنه لعمل تصنيف
اسيا يطب النوم وانا استلجنه
سعودي وزي ما ذكرنا فيها الدول المتقدمه
هذه الصين اليابان وعملنا التصنيف وكان
اساسه التصنيف السعودي مع بعض عشان يناسب
دول اسيا ممارسه الطبيه مختلفه يعني
الفلبين تايلاند كل الدول
فعملناه
قاعده في التخصص يعني فهذا يعكس لك على طب
النوم في السعودي ايضا السعودي من اوائل
الدول التي تعمل برنامج تدريب مهيكل محيكل
يعني برنامج طبي زماله طبيه
بدانا عام 2009
جعلت مكسود وخرجنا الى الان قربنا من
عشرين طبيب وطبيبه من السعوديه ودول
الخليج والطبيبه من الاردن
وكنا نعمل مع الهيئه السعوديه نحوله الى
برنامج وطني وحول الى برنامج وطني بدم
العام هذا
يعني برنامج زماله سعوديه بدل سعود يعني
زمانها السعوديه يعني معنى الان انا في في
ابها طبيب نوم
عندي كل متطلبات عمل الزماله انا ما في
داعي الاطباء عندي يروحون الرياض
انا عندي متطلبات انا ابدا برنامج الزماله
خلاص برنامج سعودي
انا في تبوك نفس القضيه عندي كذا انا في
البرياده نفس القضيه عندي خلاص انا هاي
كان هاي كان هذا انجاز
انا اعطيك مثال انه الاوروبيين
البدءوا بالشهاده الاوروبيه طبعا المانيا
عندهم كذا الشهاده الاوروبيه بداوها عملوا
امتحان عام 2012 يسمونه امتحان الجراند او
امتحان الجدود يعني يصنفون الجد عشان الجد
يبدا البرنامج
للاولاد والاحباب ونعرف لاني انا هم عملوا
100 شخص انا كنت ناول 50 شخص دخلوا
الامتحان هذا دعوني ادخل الامتحان معهم
فقلت امتحنوا يعني الامتحان هذا من
الاجداد يعني حق التخصص بعدين بداوا فيعني
هو طبعا قد يكون في برامج تدريبيه كذا
تعمل برنامج وشهاده وتصنف من الهيئه هذا
السعودي المتقدم في هذا المجال
الاكاديمي الامريكيه لطب النوم 2016
اشهر مجله تسليب مجله النوم
طب النوم العالمي اول دوله دعوها تكتب
دعونا احنا في السعوديه كتبنا مقال 2017
حتى الصين كتبوا السعودي كانت قبلهم
السعوديه
ففيه يعني لكنه ما زال عندنا طريق طويل
وما زال عنا نواقص كثير يعني ما زلنا ان
نحتاج انه نمشي في هذا الموضوع
ونحتاج يعني اتوقع في الجانب الاهم اللي
هو الوعي باهميه النوم
كيف تنام بشكل افضل وليش الواحد مهم انه
ينام علشان ما تحتاج الوعي
واحنا عملنا اكثر مسح وطني كان من حوالي
10 سنوات او تسع سنوات اخر عدد الاسر
والمحصل طب النوم في السعودي مقارنه
بالدول العالمي احنا حوالي يمكن عشوهم عدد
الاطباء
في لكل 100 الف عدد اطب النوم على الناقل
مع انه قاعد مازلنا نحتاج عدد الاطباء
اكبر كل مناطق المملكه احنا عنا بالمناسبه
في الزماله السعوديه
طبيب نوم سعودي لكل مدينه سعوديه
هذا كان شعارنا هذا شعار الزمالك فاحنا
احيانا جينا مثلا مدينه ما فيها طبيب
نعطيه الاولويه في القبول على اساس انه
نغطي المدينه بس نعطيهم يجونا
اذا هذا مثلا عندنا مثلا عندنا في الفنيين
عندنا نقص كبير والان يعني نحاول نعمل مع
الهيئه على وضع برنامج
الازمات ما زال عندنا في الخدمات المسانده
ما عندنا في توفر الادويه كل هذه الامور
ماذا عنا في البحث العلمي على اننا نشرب
حاس كثير ما زال في البحث العلمي نحتاج
لانه احنا ممكن نجي في المنطقه
يعني في عدد الابحاث لطب النوم نجي بعد
تركيا واسرائيل وايران
يجي بعدهم احنا رابع
واحنا نحتاج انه نتقدم
يعني انا اقول يعني دائما اقول لهم حتى
اقولهم احنا من الجي 20 المفروض يكون حتى
طبعا في الحلم قد يكون لكن نحتاج من البحر
العلمي يعني في كل امور دوله تسعى ومن
ضمنها ايضا البحث العلمي المفروض نكون
متقدمين في كل ابحاث يعني العلميه الصحيه
ايضا الامور اللي نحتاجه وانا حققت هذا من
الامور اللي كانت عندي من زمان واتمنى
انها تحدث وكان في محاولات لكن لم نستطيع
يعني اللي هو وضع تنظيم للقياده
عند المصابين
باضطرابات النوم وامراض النوم والامراض
الصحيه الاخرى التي تؤثر على النوم لانه
حسب علمي ما في روابط يعني واحنا يعني
التقدم اللي حاصل المملكه الان الله
القفزات الهائله اللي احنا يعني جيلي
شباب يعني احنا ممكن نلاحظ القفزات يعني
وين يعني
نحتاج انه يكون عنا تنظيم
لانه احنا عملنا بحث مره على نشوف يعني
فعلا
السيارات هذا مثبت عندنا في المملكه ما في
شك
لكن يعني 12% من اللي سوى حاجه يقول لي
اني نمت
مريض عنده امراض
يناموا في العياده عندك عنده امراض سكري
يغمى عنده ما يشوف هل تعتقد انه واجبك انك
تبلغ عنه في الجهات المسؤوله
او تقول الفاميلي يبلغوا عنه
لانه ما في نظام صحيح حتى انت لو تروح
الحين بتقول المريض انا والله ببلغ عنك
ممكن فعله عنيفه ضدك انه ما في نظام ولا
في قانون وايضا اذا انت تقول له لا تسوق
لازم
هل يدخل يدخل ضمن الاعاقه
قادر يدخل ضمن الاعاقه فيحتاج عده جهات
ووضع الانظمه
مسؤوله تنظر الامور من نظره جميع النواحي
اذا انا بقول شخص لا تسوق معناه هل انا
يكون معاقله ما اعرف يعني في الانظمه في
البلد اذا معاق هلا انا اوفر له شيء يساعد
مثلا
كاجر سائق بدل ما يسوق بعياله ويروح وكذا
وكذا مثلا
انه الحوادث المميته
اغلبها بسبب النعاس
في امريكا يعني في دول
ويدرسون
طريقه الحادث يشوفون كيف الانزلاق وكيف
كذا ويعرفون انه هذا اغلب اظنه كان نعسان
يعني مثلا حرف ودخل بسرعه عاليه هذا ما
يسويها واحد صاحبي هذا اغلب اغلب الحوادث
المميته
ينعس السائق لثواني جزء من ثانيه وجزء
ثاني انتهى الموضوع
طيب عوده على
السؤال وين يتجه
نعم عشان نسيت السؤال
انا اخذني الموضوع هذا اني ابغى اقول انه
الان طب النوم طب مصنف ما في طبيب
الان في كثير اطباء نعم عندنا احنا مجموعه
فيها اكثر من 50 طبيب يمكن ومازلنا نحتاج
اكثر لكن وين نتكلم عن اول يعني احنا
بدانا اول مركز اكاديمي عام 1418 الان
يعني وين يعني قفزات جباره يعني الحمد لله
طب النوم مهم انه ايضا يعرفون المتابعين
انه طب انه هو
قد تجد طبيب نوم عامل باطنه عامه فقط
اغلبهم مع مين صيدليه طبيب نوم جاي من
خلفيه نفسيه طبيب نوم جاي من خلفيه اعصاب
خلفيه طب عائله والمجتمع لكن في نهايه
الامر لابد ان يعمل زمان الطب النوم
ويستوفي شروط الهيئه السعوديه حتى يصنف
كطبيب نوم في اطباء الحمله عدد الاطب
السعوديين في ازدياد ليس فقط الاطباء
للباطنين اللي يعالجون القضيه هذه اصبح
عندنا اطباء الان مختصين في مثل من علاج
القطاع التنفس توكيبات الاسنان تركيبه
اسنان انه هو مجرى بلعوم يكون ضيق فالفكره
ببساطه انها تسحب الفك السفلي للامام عضه
اللسان عطله ضخمه
بهذا الحجم في الفم
مقرها كرسيها هذا كانه الكرسي وهذا اللسان
لما
يضيع هم يسحبون الفك للامام التنفس وهذا
علاج معتمد من هيئه الدواو الغذاء
الامريكيه وعليها ابحاث في اطباء اسنان
منقطه الاسنان مختصين في علاج طب النوم
ماخذين الشهادات المختصه من في اطباء
اسنان من جراحي الوجه والفكين مختصين في
عمليه الوجه والفكين اللي توسع متجر
التنفس هذا ايضا في اطباء السعوديه الان
موجود تخصص ايضا نادر يعني وبدا الان في
مجموعه من الزملاء في اطباء سعودي الان
ايضا يرجعون مختصين في عمليات الحلق ويضع
من تخصص في جراحه النوم
في اجهزه مثلا زراعه منظم تحت الجلد العصب
اللسان في اطباء مختصين فيها قد يكون
بعضهم ما يمارس الى الاعلى ما وفقونه لكن
عدد الاطباء من الشباب الان في ازدياد
والوعي بين القطاع الصحي من طلبه الطب
والخليجين جديد مثلا كانوا عملوا مبادره
هناك سعود
ودعوني لها انا احضر يعني
مسابقه الطلبه سنه ثانيه وجدت انا من ضمن
المتسابقين كان مجموعتين عن النوم
وحده كانت
توعظ ظاهر باهميه النوم او شيء من هذا
القبيل ووحده عن المرضى انه يعني حتى
الطلبه بدا عندهم يعني الوعي انه هذا
موضوع مهم لكن ما زال امامنا مشوار طويل
والشباب يعني
الشباب يعني القاعده ان شاء الله يعني
الله يعطيك العافيه والله شكرا لجيتك شكرا
لك الله يجزاكم خير
شكرا لكم شكرا لايمن الحمادي وعلاء الحاج
في اعداد الحلقه وهب موسى في التصوير
وجميل
عطاس في التلوين وفي الهندسه الصوتيه ضياء
الدين مدني واداره التحرير اسيل بن عبد
الله هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع ننشر كل الانتاج بحب من
مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل القاك
في واحده من السلوكيات
لانه يسمع علشان ينام
في ناس من زمان كانت
وبعدين جت القنوات عادل المحليه السعوديه
وكذا يسمعونها وينام
ما في مشكله
الحين تلقى يحطون خيار النوم فيخليه شغال
مثلا لمده 15 دقيقه بعدين يدفع عشان
ممتاز يعني ما في شيء
خليني ابغاك تقييم نومي
يعني انا اقيس النوم
يعرف كم مده ما تكلمنا عن التطبيقات هذه
وجودتها جودتها جيده لا انا عندي مقال
اسمه
الجديد اشارته الاكاديميه الامريكيه لطب
النوم شغلته جديد يعني
يعني الناس اللي تعتقد انها بتتابع
بالجهاز هذا نومها دقيق جدا وكيف ممكن
يعطيك انطباع خاطئ
انه اذا كنت لو ما تحققت وما كذا يعطيك
طبعا
انت صاحي
يعني
سميناه
لانه هذا مهم ناس تعتقد وكتبنا بعضهم بعده
مقال قبل
الرياضيات رياضيين بعضهم بالنوم يزيد
فيعتقد انه الجهاز هذا دقيق يعني كان
العنوان حقها يعني بس انا بخليك تشوفها
لانه الجهاز مو دقيق على كل حال الاجهزه
هذه ما هي دقيقه
يعني على الاقل تقدر تفهم ما هو
تصور خاطئ
الامريكيه هذا في في فبراير اشارت الى
مقالنا كود ذا وايت
مراقبه نومك اوف سليب يوزن
اللي عنوانه بالانجليزي انا ترجمته
بالعربي
غمض عيوني
فيعطيك انطباع خاطئ ويؤخر التشخيص
وقد يخدع الرياضيين
هو ما هو نايم قلت انام كويس لكن تعبان
لا الجهاز هذا موجود مثل افضل
[موسيقى]
يعني لازم الجهاز يتاكد انه عليه
دراسه علميه ويتحققون
ضد دراسه النوم
بس ما يعطيك مراحل النوم طبعا انسان طبيعي
ما عنده مشكله
يعطيكم مراحل النوم يعطيك مراحل
نشوف هذا العريض الاحلام فوق وهذا استيقاظ
وهذا تحت النوم العميق فهذا مو دقيق
انت لو تعمل له هذا ضد تخطيط النوم بيطلع
غلط مو دقيق يعني
لكنه يعني هذا اللي حاطه هنا طبيعي وجميل
شوف زي ما قلت اقول لك الاحلام تزيد في
نهايه النوم والنوم العميق في اول النوم
هذا الطبيعي هذا الطبيعي شوف ابنه يعني
[موسيقى]
الاحلام وهذا الديب تحت هذا ما راح نوم
الاخف وهذا استيقاظ فوق الخفيف
فيعني هو اذا الشخص ما عنده اعراض لكن اذا
عنده اعراض مما يعتمد عليه
يقيس طبعا اكسجين الدم
نبضات القلب
ايش كمان هو الاكسجين وهذا ممكن يقاس
بحساس لكن القضيه المهمه انه في نهائي
لازم يكون
لانه كيف الاكسجين يقاس
هذا يروحوا يقيس
الهيموجلوبين المؤكسد طبعا
الانسان الطبيعي جيد لكن مثلا تعرض
فكثير من الاجهزه هذه تاخذ لك دقيقه 30
ثانيه فلما تاخذ الابل يطلع طبيعي فيحتاج
يكون جهاز فيه فاست سامبلين يعني
السامبلين السريع ياكل ثانيه قبل الكثير
ثلاث ثواني يعطيك قراءه فاحيانا اللي
عندهم نقص اكسجين متواصل يكتشفها بس اللي
عندهم متقطع هذا ما يقدر التنفس شوي ويفتح
ويرجع بس ما يكتشف ايضا وايضا مثلا واحد
مدخن قد يكون اكسيد ناقص ما يعطيه لانه
يزيد عنده اول اكسيد الكربون وهذا ما يقرا
الا يعني
الطيف الاخر ما يعرف ما يعرف يقيسه يعطيك
قراءه طبيعيه حينها كثير مع
التقليديه مدحت حطب ولا دفايه غاز وطالعين
مخيم ولا شيء يجيهم الدوخه وغثيان وكذا
هدولا يمكن لو بيطمن اكسجين طبيعي مو
طبيعي
وفيها يعني اللي يبغى يعرف اذا يشخر في
الغرفه تطبيق السليب سايكل اللي هو يقيس
بالمايكروفون
الجوال تقدر تحطه جنب السرير فهو يسجل
لحظات الشخير ويسجلها لك تروح تسمعها
بعضهم بعضهم مقاطع واذا سمعتها اقول لهم
هذا عندهم قطاع التنفس
بعدين يبدا يشتغل لانه
اذا قطع النفس وقف الشيخ
مقفول تماما بعدين يفتح استيقاظ في الدماغ
شوي بعد يقفل ثاني لواحد سجل مثلا استخدم
تطبيق وجرب ولقيني شاخر اغلب اليوم اغلبك
يروح الدكتور والله المفروض
تعبان بالذات اذا كان
يعني يقطع ثوان بعدين في قطاع التنفس يصيب
الشباب يعني ممكن يصيب الشباب بالذات لانه
له علاقه بالوراثه والعلاقه والفكين
والسفلي وفكين راجعين مع بعض احنا كثير من
المجتمع لانه ملتحي
على طول حتى يحتاج له تقييم
على ولي الدين كنت اقول لام سلمان هذا ودي
يجي يعالجه ههه
اكيد لانه المزدوج
اللي عندهم
شوق حتى يلعبون حديد
فهو هذا علاء ولي الدين
كان في العيد ضحى ونام بعد الفجر
وتوفى رحمه الله عليه
هذا جنه مرحله الاحلام مشكله مره اخرى
انقطاع التنفس في الاحلام شديد جدا جدا
ويزيد في الاحلام ويزيد نقص الاكسجين لانه
رده فعل الدماغ تبطئ في الاحلام لنقص
الاكسجين فين بشكل كبير ومده الانقطاع
تزيد
وفي الاحلام زين ما قلنا انه دقات القلب
واحتياج القلب خلال القلب اكسجين يزداد
اذا اضفت انقطاع التنفس نقص الاكسجين اذا
زاد دقات القلب
لاحتياج خلايا القلب للاكسجين الى مريض
عنده تسلق في الشرايين اصلا في حقه القلب
حنظيف الشرايين اجتمعت هذه كلها تجي جلط
القلب وش الوقت الملائم لها بعد الفجر
لانه كله كله احلام اغلبه احلام كثير من
الناس يقول لك صلى الفجر ونام وتوفى توفي
صحيح توفي فتوفي طبعا ممكن اي شيء توفي
لكنه هذا الوقت اللي فيه خطا الاعلى في
الاحلام هذا الوقت لاعلى انه يجيهم
الجلطه في القلب او جلطه في الدماغ
بعصه
لابد انه يستخدم الجهاز
وشنو ممكن يعني ممكن
الفك في مشكله او عضله اللسان هو طبعا في
عام الوراثي في الموضوع فيكون حلققهم ضيق
هو مرض يصيب متوسط
الاطفال يصير عندهم لوز عاده لحميات اغلب
الاطفال التدخل الجراحي في العاده الكبار
اغلب الاحيان يكون حل الحل ضعيف مع زياده
الوزن 60%
والفك العلوي والسفلي غير هذه ما في يعني
نادرا في الكبار نحصل احيانا بس اغلب لغه
لكن كل مثلا يجيك 560
يعطيكم العافيه جزاكم الله خير
[ضحك]
يعطيكم العافيه
استوعب لما كنت تتكلم دكتور ان ابوي عنده
هذا من المشخر تحصل به القطاعته يقطع
النفس
وعندك الفكين صغار الفكين صغار هي صغير
بالضبط لانه وش المشكله هي اللسان عضله
ضخمه
جالسه بالكرسي هذا بالفك ولم يرجع الفك وش
اللي وراه الحلق زي انت لو هنا جالس ورجعت
الكرسي المساحه تضيق المساحه تضيق المساحه
تقفل احيانا
[ضحك]